monsieur jancovici cher aux étudiantes
et étudiants demandent à
l'administration un doute l'extérieur
c'est un plaisir de vous voir aussi
nombreux ce soir pour la conférence
inaugurale de leurs tweets 2020 d'achat
c'est paris monsieur jean marc jancovici
c'est un honneur de vous recevoir sur
notre campus que vous avez vaillamment
rejoint à vélo ce soir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
on me toute l'équipe d'achat ces débats
j'aimerais l'avoir félicité l'équipe
espère font leur travail et vous
remercier leur proposer d'organiser
cette conférence en collaboration avec
vous merci également à nos sponsors
le cabinet d'audit et de conseil mazars
journal les grandes écoles et le figaro
économie
enfin je vous rappelle qu'il aura un
buffet à l'issue de cette conférence qui
a été spécialement préparée par
l'association la sauce et qui sera
également une opportunité pour vous de
prolonger les échanges avec nos slogans
8 6 sans plus attendre je laisse la
parole les équipes d'espèrer je me
souhaite à tous une très bonne confiance
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur jean policiers d'avoir
fait le déplacement pour nous faire
profiter de votre expertise sur le
climat et l'énergie
cette conférence co-organisée par espère
achever ce débat et point réveil
écologique et l'événement inaugural de
l'afrique nous réfléchissons à ce projet
depuis l'an dernier et nous sommes
heureux de vous présenter cette première
édition de la homestory qu ousmane de la
terre pour les défenseurs de la langue
française
celle ci est une réaction au sentiment
que les étudiants sont trop peu
sensibilisés aux enjeux actuels
climatique depuis septembre et renforcé
d'une équipe de dizaines d'étudiants du
soutien du séno center et de nombreuses
associations étudiantes dachau c'est que
nous tenons à remercier
nous avons multiplié les événements pour
que cette semaine touche le plus de
personnes et devienne un réel catalyseur
de prise de conscience
donc voici le programme si vous n'en
avez pas encore pris connaissance à
travers ces différents événements notre
objectif est d'aider les étudiants a
changé durablement leur mode de
consommation en les sensibilisant d'une
part à l'impact de leur mode de vie et
d'autre part en leur proposant des
solutions concrètes loin de la
culpabilisation c'est un message dans
enthousiaste d'espoir que nous portons
et qui nous l'espérons dépassera les
frontières du campus nous sommes fiers
d'être à l'initiative du projet du
premier projet écologique de cette
ampleur sur le campus de hec et nous
espérons qu'il se renouvellera tous les
ans je laisse désormais la place à
marion pour présenter le parcours de
notre conférencière
les signaux alarmistes concernant la
finitude des ressources accumule les
débats économiques entre croissance
verte et des croissances pullulent et
l'espace médiatique est encombré par
l'énième anecdotes du journaliste revenu
à la terre la tribune du politically
matteau négationnistes oui l'inévitable
article sur les ours polaires
au milieu de cette cacophonie il reste
des certitudes
nous sommes convaincus que nous courons
vers une catastrophe environnementale et
sociale nous observons déjà les
conséquences
nous sommes pourtant conscient de ses
causes un système économique qui
n'intègre pas la finitude des ressources
de la planète et des comportements
individuels visible au centre desquels
se trouve la surconsommation et le
gaspillage l'urgence écologique est là
et c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
messieurs jean marc jancovici
polytechnicien de formation vous êtes
engagés dans les questions climatiques
et énergétiques dès la fin des années
1990 scientiste pro-nucléaire pour lézan
dangereux décroissant néo malthusiens
pour les autres votre parole ne laisse
personne indifférent et autant l'avouer
votre parole est assez déprimante voire
franchement noir vous partez du constat
que l'économie entière des pays
occidentaux est basée sur une énergie
abondante et à bas prix il s'agit pour
une majeure partie d'énergie fossile
présente en quantité limitée et
précipitant le dérèglement climatique
il s'ensuit alors de grandes
perturbations à prévoir à l'échelle
mondiale événements climatiques extrêmes
stress hydrique pénuries alimentaires
déplacements de populations révolte
sociale
doit-on alors vous disqualifier à force
de catastrophisme absolument pas vous
n'êtes pas réductible à une cassandre
médiatique co-inventeur du bilan carbone
outils d'évaluation de la contribution à
l'effet de serre et de la dépendance de
combustibles fossibles vous avez co
fondé en 2007 avec monsieur alain
grandjean de carbone 4 le premier
cabinet de conseil en stratégie carbone
et votre engagement ne s'arrête pas là
en 2010 vous fonder et présider le chief
project think-tank tentant de répondre à
la double contrainte du carbone à savoir
le changement climatique et la
raréfaction des ressources énergétiques
fossiles vous escrimée à vouloir
infléchir la direction que nous prenons
vous préconisez à la france de se lancer
de manière résolue massive et ordonnée
dans la reconstruction de son économie
vieillissante
il ya une véritable transition
énergétique des transports efficaces et
une décarbonisation de l'industrie afin
d'embarquer l'europe et le reste du
monde dans cette lutte par effet de
mimétisme
beaucoup on vous accusera dès lors bien
volontiers d'être utopiste mais qui
aujourd'hui est le véritable utopiste
celui qui appelle à changer de
trajectoire ou plutôt en affirmant que
la situation actuelle est chaque jour
plus insoutenable ou celui qui affirme
que tout peut continuer comme avant
le changement est inéluctable et ceux
qui se refusent à le voir aujourd'hui
seront contraints dans vingt ans de le
subir
il s'agit dès lors de sortir de notre
pardon il s'agit de sortir de votre
approche purement mercantilisme et de ne
pas oublier l'interdépendance et la co
évolution entre les sociétés humaines et
les écosystèmes
il s'agit de réinventer notre système
pour qu'il soit économiquement viable et
écologiquement soutenable un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour monsieur jean
marc jancovici
[Applaudissements]
bon c'est gentil d'avoir invité un
voisin je ne sais pas si c'est être j'ai
passé un des coupables de délits
d'initiés quand on investit dans un
fabricant d'antidépresseurs d'aller
faire des conférences je reconnais un
juriste dans la salle qui pourra
peut-être me dire ça donc il faut que
vous déprime et bien des prix ou non je
vais essayer de très rapidement de fait
vous êtes un des primes à bhl c'est
parce que vous savez que les jeunes tant
qu'on est éternel et invincible enfin
tant que ce sens éternelle est
invincible et donc normalement à votre
âge vous n'êtes pas des primes à bhl je
vais vous raconter deux trois petits
trucs en fait vous allez mettre très
joyeux parce que si vous comprenez bien
ce que je vais vous raconter il y en a
une partie d'entre vous qui se sentiront
toute assez décontracté à l'idée de ne
pas aller en cours d'économie
donc je suis sûr que vous me remercierez
chaudement appréciant la base de ce que
je vais vous raconter la voix si vous
avez ici une photo de la terre vue de
l'espace
on prête soit dit en passant au fait
d'avoir commencé à voir la terre vue de
l'espace la naissance d'un certain
nombre de mouvements environnementaux à
la fin des années 60 et au début des
années 70 parce que c'est à ce moment là
qu'on s'est rendu compte avec nos sens
et nous restons des animaux donc on aime
bien apprécié le monde avec nos sens que
la terre était finie et qu'elle était
donc qu'elle avait une taille fine et
alors de fête la terre à une taille
finie et alors non seulement la terre la
taille de la terre est fini mais elle a
une sale manie la taille de la terre
c'est qu'elle ne varie pas au cours du
temps il ya quelques siècles la terre
faisait treize mille kilomètres de
diamètre puis aujourd'hui c'est encore
le cas et puis dans deux siècles sera
toujours désespérément treize mille
kilomètres de diamètre
aucun entrepreneur génial issus des
grandes affiches qui traînent dans le
couloir là devait arriver avec une pompe
à vélo et gonflé un peu le diamètre de
la terre pour qu'on puisse
marchera pas il va falloir qu'on fasse
avec alors elle a une caractéristique
cette terre de 13 mille kilomètres de
diamètre qu'on ne vous enseigne
peut-être pas suffisamment en cours
d'économie qui est qu'elle est gratuite
en fait tout ce qui est strictement
indispensables l'asie est en fait en
particulier qu'on ait un système
économique est totalement gratuit je
vais prendre année 1 une des
caractéristiques de la terre c'est
qu'elle a une atmosphère cette
atmosphère comporte 20 % d'oxygène si
demain matin la teneur en oxygène tombé
à zéro vous mourrez tous je meurs tout
le monde meurt et le pib passe à 0
le fait qu'il y ait 20 % d'oxygène dans
l'atmosphère terrestre est invisible
dans la totalité des prix que vous allez
manipulé dans cette école c'est
invisible alors que pourtant si je n'ai
pas ces 20% en oxygène dans l'atmosphère
vous n'avez pas de prix bic a plus
personne
voilà donc c'est quelque chose alors j'y
reviendrai dans le cours de cet exposé
c'est quelque chose qui est un des
billets majeur des raisonnements
économiques aujourd'hui c'est que
l'économie ne compte plus ce qui compte
vraiment alors l'économie de compte plus
ceux qui comprennent sur cette petite
planète qui fait désespérément treize
mille kilomètres de diamètre
il y à l'espèce qui s'appelle l'espèce
humaine qui était tellement bien adapté
à dominer son environnement et les
autres espèces qu'elle s'est retrouvée
sans compétiteur et qu'elle en a profité
pour prospérer de manière extrêmement
significative alors l'insee était pas
extrêmement performant qui a dix mille
ans mais enfin on va dire que même si le
recensement était fait avec un peu
d'approximations il y avait à cette
époque la rai et 10000 ans au moment où
la population c'est dans ta favorise
hommes sont sédentarisés et ils se
sédentarisent parce que la planète sort
de la grande transition climatique
glaciaires et interglaciaires dernière
grande transition climatique qu'elle est
connue donc le climat va devenir stable
pendant dix mille ans et donc les gens
peuvent s'installer quelque part et
faire toujours la même chose ça marche à
ce moment là on est quelques millions
d'individus avant le début de la
révolution industrielle nous sommes
quelques centaines de millions
d'individus bon vous voyez en a quand
même bien prospéré en l'espace de deux
siècles
la population a été multipliée par allez
on
à dire un gros facteur 10 un facteur 15
alors pour ceux d'entre vous qui sont
pas totalement allergique aux maths
quand vous voyez cette courbe on est au
delà de l'exploit n'en ciel on est plus
proche de l'hyperbole bon et on se dit
raisonnablement quand on voit ce truc là
que ce n'est pas complètement sûr que ça
va durer pendant la nuit des temps qu'on
va rester à 8 millions dans le même
temps les hommes se sont mis à utiliser
de plus en plus d'énergie vous avez ici
la quantité d'énergie qui est mobilisée
par personne sur terre
donc c'est une moyenne mondiale hors
bois j'ai évacué le bois dans cette
affaire donc c'est toutes les énergies
commercial moderne on va dire depuis
alors je vous épargne la règle de trois
vu de ce graphique la quantité d'énergie
qui est utilisé par personne a été
multiplié par vingt alors quoi je vous
parle d'énergie parce que l'énergie en
physique
c'est ce qui caractérise le changement
du monde physique l'énergie en fait
c'est une grandeur qui a été inventé par
les physiciens pour quantifier et je dis
bien quantifier ou qu'il ya des nombres
derrière la face à la quantité de
changements que vous introduisez dans un
système plus il ya d'énergie qui entrent
en jeu dans une réaction plus le système
se transforme
c'est ça c'est ça l'idée ce qui veut
dire que l'énergie mobilisée par les
hommes et je vais y revenir juste après
c'est le marqueur de la transformation
de l'environnement par personne plus une
personne consomme d'énergie plus elle
transforme son environnement et donc
plus au premier ordre
elle a des effets indésirables liés à
cette transformation est aussi d'effets
bénéfiques qui à cette transformation
vous aviez deux donc si vous dites que
l'impact de l'homme sur son
environnement c'est là le nombre
d'individus fois la quantité d'énergie
par personne vous avez ici au premier
ordre
la façon dont a évolué la pression des
hommes sur l'environnement sur une
planète qui fait toujours désespérément
treize mille kilomètres de diamètre et
donc ça vous explique pourquoi pour des
raisons d'ordre de grandeur tout un tas
de sujets qui n'étaient pas des
problèmes il ya deux siècles sont en
train de devenir des problèmes majeurs
aujourd'hui tout simplement parce que
les ordres de grandeur ont
considérablement changé
et alors là je vais finir par une
première conclusion provisoire
on ne sort jamais d'un débat sur
l'environnement sans manipuler des
chiffres dit autrement tant qu'on est
sur les slogans on va nulle part
pour sortir correctement c'est comme on
ne sort jamais d'un débat sur l'économie
sans chiffres d'accord entre une dette
de 1 euro et une dette de 10 milliards
d'euros on parle pas de la même chose
donc là c'est exactement pareil en ce
qui concerne l'environnement on ne sort
jamais d'un débat sur l'environnement
sans chiffres tant qu'on est dans les
slogans et on n'en est rien c'est
dommage parce que le politique gère
essentiellement c'est à coup de slogans
donc de l'énergie j'y reviens c'est ce
qui permet de quantifier le changement
dans le monde qui nous entoure
c'est ça le c'est ça la définition de
l'énergie alors quelques quelques deux
ou trois petits trucs qu'il faut avoir
en tête en ce qui concerne l'énergie
vous savez que l'énergie étant une
grandeur physique elle est régie par des
lois qui ne dépendent pas de nous
c'est pour ça je n'en discutait juste
avant la conférence là que je pense que
les ingénieurs sont un peu plus
fataliste que les commerçants il se
croit un peu moins maître du monde parce
qu'ils passent leur temps à étudier des
trucs qui dépendent pas de dons qu'ils
se sentent du coup un peu moins envie de
tout changer
voilà de l'autre côté comme on passe son
temps à évoluer des trucs qui ne sont
que des conventions humaine m'économiser
qu'une convention humaine bah du coup on
se dit que c'est probablement plus
facile de changer les choses
sauf que vous êtes comme les ingénieurs
soumis aux lois de la physique que vous
n'êtes pas capables de changer pour plus
que voiture est donc il vaut mieux les
connaître
alors dans les lois qu'on ne peut pas
changer en ce qui concerne l'énergie il
y en a une qui est absolument capital
qui s'appelle la loi de conservation est
alors comme le dictionnaire est bien
fait cette loi de conservation a dit une
chose c'est que dans un système qui ne
communiquent pas vous n'avez pas de
modification de la quantité d'énergie
qui les contenus dit autrement vous
prenez un système qui ne communiquent
pas avec l'extérieur
la quantité d'énergie à l'intérieur est
rigoureusement constante au cours du
temps
si vous appliquez ça à l'humanité ça
veut dire que tant que l'humanité ne
communique pas avec l'extérieur elle ne
peut pas utiliser d'énergie alors je
vais vous le dire encore autrement la
seule énergie que nous pouvons utiliser
c'est celle qui existe déjà dans
l'environnement et qu'on peut mobiliser
à notre profit alors ça peut vous
paraître un peu ésotérique ce que je
suis en train de vous dire mais dans les
débats actuels
il ya des tas de gens qui disent par
exemple aurait utilisé de l'hydrogène
bas l'hydrogène y en a pas dans
l'environnement donc l'hydrogène faut le
faire avec autre chose
recourir à l'hydrogène n'est pas une
solution à nos problèmes tout simplement
parce que ça ne dit pas comment vous
fabriquez d'hydrogène recourir à
l'électricité sauf à brancher les
cafetières sur les éclairs d'orage
c'est pareil c'est pas quelques
ce que vous pouvez faire en allant
directement taper dans l'environnement
il faut dire comment on fait
l'électricité donc les seules énergies
qu'on peut utiliser sont celles qui
existent dans l'environnement
essentiellement des trucs qui brûle soit
dit en passant
et pour pouvoir utiliser cette énergie
il faut la mettre dans quelque chose qui
réagit avec cette énergie et qu'on
appelle un convertisseur alors
historiquement on a un convertisseur
sous la main au moment où dieu créé adam
et eve c'est nous mêmes nous sommes à
convertisseur d'énergie alors on a une
énergie que on va chercher dans
l'environnement surtout les hommes ça
s'appelle de la nourriture
les femmes préfèrent le soleil non on va
chercher dans l'environnement la chaleur
du soleil et de quoi manger et avec ça
on va fournir du travail un peu et la
chaleur qui nous permet de nous matière
à 37° beaucoup et puis avec le temps
comme on est des animaux intelligents on
s'est dit on doit pouvoir faire un peu
mieux que serra et on s'est mis à se
dire qu'on pouvait mobiliser à notre
profit d'autres convertisseur qui nous
ressemblent des convertisseurs
biologique c'est la domestication des
animaux esclavage donc les
convertisseurs supplémentaires qu'un
homme peut avoir à sa disposition dans
les temps très anciens et bien c'est des
animaux ou ses semblables qui la réduit
en esclavage
arrive ensuite un temps dans l'histoire
où les hommes se disent on doit pouvoir
encore exploiter d'autres trucs et à ce
moment c'est l'essor des énergies
renouvelables
on commence à exploiter le vent avec la
marine et les moulins on exploite clos
avec les moulins on exploite
essentiellement c'est d'autres classes
et puis il ya deux siècles
il ya encore d'autres personnes qui
découvrent que l'on peut utiliser des
convertisseurs fait de métal qui
s'appelle des moteurs alors ses premiers
moteurs c'est des machines à vapeur
ensuite on a inventé les moteurs à
combustion interne dans les deux cas de
figure c'est des machines fait de métal
et elles sont capables de mobiliser une
énergie que vous vous n'êtes pas
capables d'utiliser en direct parce que
personne dans cette salle n'a bu du
pétrole ou en tout cas pas en trouvant
sa très bon et c'est des combustibles
fossiles donc pour avoir été capable
d'utiliser les combustibles fossiles il
a fallu non seulement qu'on ait ces
combustibles qu'on les trouve etc mais
qu'ont également les convertisseurs qui
permettent de s'en servir
donc là vous avez très résumée
l'histoire des hommes et de l'énergie
donc la transition énergétique ça fait
cinq cent mille ans qu'on en fait cent
mille ans qu'on en fait chez les hommes
par contre quelque chose qu'il faut
avoir en tête dès maintenant c'est que
quand vous utilisez de l'énergie en fait
ce que vous utilisez ce n'est pas de
l'énergie c'est une machine donc c'est
un convertisseur donc aujourd'hui une
machine donc utiliser de plus en plus
d'énergie en pratique ça veut dire avoir
de plus en plus de machines à son
service c'est ça que ça veut dire
l'énergie c'est pas pour la beauté de
l'énergie que on en utilise on s'en
fiche complètement pour la beauté de
l'énergie ce qui est important c'est le
fait que ça permet de mettre en route
des esclaves des temps modernes c'est à
dire des machines alors comme on trouve
ça très sympa de l'énergie on en utilise
de plus en plus vous avez ici la
quantité totale d'énergie mobilisés par
les hommes depuis un siècle et demi soit
dit en passant vous voyez un truc
intéressant c'est que toutes les
d'énergie depuis un siècle et demi
s'empilent les unes sur les autres
il n'y a jamais eu de substitution à
large échelle d'une énergie par une
autre et aujourd'hui les éoliennes ne
remplace rien du tout elle se rajoute
sur le reste il n'y a pas de
substitution à l'échelle mondiale soit
10,1 quelque chose qui va avoir en tête
également c'est que le monde
renouvelables qui en ce moment est dans
tous les esprits en disant ah ça serait
quand même vachement bien si on y allait
etc c'est celui dont on sort en fait
c'est pas celui vers lequel on va enfin
on y retournera peut-être mais c'est
surtout celui dont on sort alors
quelques exemples vous avez ici un
bateau d'il ya quelques siècles et vous
voyez c'est un bateau 100 % renouvelable
en fin de vie à trois figures mais à
part ça il est 100% renouvelable
il a des voiles en coton ou en lin
renouvelables monte sur des mâts en bois
renouvelables sur une coque en bois
renouvelables avec des marins tout à
fait renouvelables qui mangent pas assez
de citron renouvelables donc il est
rappelé au score but et on s'est dit
c'est quand même vachement mieux pour
faire venir tout un tas de trucs très
sympathique de l'autre côté de la terre
d'avoir une arène facile ça marche mieux
donc on va fossilisés la marine vous
avez ici des transports terrestres
parfaitement renouvelables donc avec un
cheval qui mangent de l'herbe
renouvelables je parle aussi et
renouvelables tirant une charrette en
bois renouvelables des terrains et on
s'est dit non quand même pour avoir des
transports qui coûte pas cher et qui
permettent de transporter des tas de
trucs c'est quand même vachement mieux
de fossilisés les transports faut aussi
disons les transports vous avez ici une
agriculture renouvelables avec des
tracteurs renouvelables s'appelle des
animaux de trait
tirant une charrue renouvelables etc
manger de l'herbe renouvelables et on
s'est dit non quand même pour avoir le
panini pour patcher là juste devant
c'est quand même vachement mieux d'avoir
un tracteur fossiles ça coûte beaucoup
moins cher
effectivement ça coûte beaucoup moins
cher voici des travaux publics
renouvelables avec lesquels on ne
pouvait pas faire des ronds points sont
essentiels
et voilà de quoi faire des ronds points
pour pêcheurs beaucoup plus efficace
nous avions de la construction
renouvelable avec des ouvriers mangeant
de la nourriture redoutable et avançant
fouetter par un fois renouvelable comme
dans astérix et cléopâtre et on s'est
dit que c'était quand même vachement
mieux pour faire les grands cornichons à
la défense là d'avoir de la construction
fossiles que ça allait beaucoup plus
vite nous avions une industrie
renouvelables avec des moulins à eau
parfois avant mais souvent à eau
renouvelable fait à l'emploi etc et on
s'est dit que pour faire les millions et
les dizaines de millions de produits que
nous avons aujourd'hui à notre
disposition c'est quand même vachement
mieux d'avoir de l'industrie fossile et
fut un temps également où on laissait
les récoltes sécher au soleil
renouvelables et maintenant les récoltes
on les sèche dans des séchoirs à gaz et
c'est quand même vachement mieux donc ça
fait deux siècles que nous passons notre
temps à aller des énergies renouvelables
vers les énergies fossiles alors ou bien
nos ancêtres sont des crétins
malfaisants patentés ou bien ils ont
fait ça pour une très bonne raison et
c'est justement le défi de notre temps
parce que ils ont fait ça pour une très
bonne raison c'est que les énergies
fossiles sont physiquement
intrinsèquement très supérieur aux
énergies renouvelables
ça permet de tout faire beaucoup plus
vite pour beaucoup moins cher et donc de
passer aux énergies renouvelables
ça contractera globalement le système
économique je vais y revenir après mais
en gros c'est ça le défi dans l'énergie
a permis de mettre en route tout a pas
de machine
voilà un tout petit bout de notre
costume de superman des temps modernes
grâce auquel la puissance de nos bras et
x des milliers la puissance de nos
jambes et x des milliers la puissance de
nos bras et parfois multipliée par des
dizaines de millions quand on pilote à
la mémoire industrielle et toutes ces
machines qui fonctionnent sur terre
elles ont permis de démultiplier la
puissance musculaire des hommes par 210
autrement aujourd'hui dans les fonctions
de production que vous étudiez c'est pas
les hommes qui compte et c'est pas la
générosité des banquiers qui compte
c'est les machines c'est les machines
qui produisent les vêtements que vous
portez ont été produits par des machines
et chaises sur lesquelles vous êtes
assis et ceux qui s'emmerdent déjà
roupille et bien ont été produits par
des machines
la caméra kim film a été produite par
une machine le vélo qui va amener ici
est produit par une machine
mon ordinateur est lui-même une machine
etc nous vivons dans un monde de
machines la nourriture que j'ai mangé il
ya une demi heure a été produite par une
machine
les tracteurs des moissonneuses
batteuses et cetera des silos des
groupes de froid tout ce que les
machines d'accord c'est les machines qui
produisent aujourd'hui c'est pas vous
c'est pas moi et c'est même pas les
ouvriers les gens sont là pour donner
des ordres aux machines mais ce qui
produit ces les machines sauf que cet
homme là vous que vous connaissez
peut-être
eh bien il ya deux siècles
il a dit les machines ça compte pas et
du reste les ressources naturelles ça
compte pas tout simplement parce qu'il
ya deux siècles n'y a pas de machines et
les ressources naturelles sont pas un
facteur limitant ce qui est limite ans
il ya deux siècles c'est la quantité de
gens au travail et le capital humain et
donc au moment où l'économie vous êtes
en train d'apprendre aujourd'hui a été
fait il ya deux siècles et n'a pas
changé depuis et n'a pas changé depuis
ondimba dans l'économie il ya deux
facteurs limitants et deux seulement
donc c'est le capital humain et le
travail humain et le reste on s'en fout
donc ce que vous apprenez ici c'est que
un système productif est alimenté par
deux facteurs de production tous les
deux humains soit dit en passant et ça
ça suffit pour que le supermarché soient
remplies et si le supermarché n'est pas
assez rempli on botte le cul des
banquiers on botte le cul des chômeurs
et on dit comme ça le pib va repartir
alors ça fait dix ans qu'on essaye de
faire sahara depuis 2007
et comme disait ma fille quand elle
avait deux ans pourtant ça mieux pas
d'accord l'économie continue à flag à
douille et la croissance se traîne et en
fait quand vous regardez d'où il ya la
croissance est bien d'autres trucs qui
n'existe pas en fait c'est de
l'inflation d'actifs
bâtie à coups de dettes etc mais il n'y
a plus de croissance physique depuis
2007 ya plus la raison à cela c'est que
ce que vous avez là sous le nez est une
mauvaise représentation du système en
termes physiques en termes physiques
pour que vous ayez les produits dans le
supermarché
il faut que vous ayez les ressources que
vous avez transformé pour faire ces
produits tous les atomes de fer que vous
avez dans vos vêtements parce que vous
avez des boucles de ceinture des boutons
etc
ils n'ont pas été créées par harry
potter ils viennent de l'environnement
vous ne faites pas de boutons en faire
si vous n'avez pas de faire ne peut pas
donc tous les produits et tous les
services bâti sur les produits parce que
même pour faire de la finance il faut
des ordinateurs il ya quarante métaux
différents dans un ordinateur et ses
produits absolument partout il n'y a pas
de service totalement dématérialisé ça
n'existe pas eh bien tous les éléments
physiques constituant de notre économie
ils ont besoin de ressources pour être
fabriqué donc il faut des ressources
pour alimenter le système économique
aussi est il faut une capacité à
transformer ses ressources c'est donc le
travail et ce travail avec ce que je
viens de vous expliquer juste avant et
pour l'essentiel fait par des machines
pour une toute petite partie par notre
force musculaire mais pour l'essentiel
par des machines
le capital dans cette affaire il est
fabriqué est exactement comme les biens
de consommation exactement pareil en
transformant des ressources cet immeuble
a été fait en transformant des
ressources ya pas de différence avec
votre paire de chaussettes
enfin bon ça va pas exactement le même
usage mais qu'ils sont meilleurs mais à
part ça c'est exactement le même
processus de fabrication
c'est à dire qu'on a pris des ressources
naturelles dans l'environnement et on
les a transformés pour faire autre chose
parce qu'on a trouvé que c'était mieux
pour nous ce que vous voyez sur ce
graphique c'est que à l'évidence si vous
avez un stress sur la quantité d'énergie
disponible vous aurez un stress sur le
pib en sortie même si vous avez des tas
de gens prêts à travailler et même si
vous avez des banquiers très
compatissant donc il n'ya pas que les
hommes et les travailleurs et banquiers
dans les facteurs limitants de
l'économie il ya aussi l'énergie et il y
as soit dit en passant aussi les
ressources naturelles
vous savez que les poissons apparaissent
tout seul dans la mer parce qu'ils
baissent dedans comme dit renault ce qui
est dégueulasse donc la pêche profite
d'une ressource qui apparaît
spontanément dans la mer qui et les
poissons cette ressource est gratuite
comme tout ce que nous donne mère-nature
beau zéro
si vous n'avez plus de poissons dans la
mer vous pouvez avoir un crédit maritime
ou un crédit coopératif très très
compréhensifs
le pib de la pêche sera nulle et soit
dit en passant le pib de tous ceux qui a
l'aval du poisson sera nul aussi donc
les restaurants la criée font faillite
la belle iloise fait faillite et le
restaurant de poissons du coin fait
faillite et c'est les gens qui fabrique
des boîtes de conserve pour poissons
font faillite et les transporteurs de
poissons font faillite à tout ce beau
monde fait faillite alors même que la
ressource qui permet à tous ces gens-là
d'exister est gratuite tout simplement
parce qu'elle n'est plus là alors à
cause du fait que c'est essentiellement
les machines qui produisait pas les
hommes voilà ce que je considère être le
meilleur modèle macroéconomique qu'on
puisse vous montrer c'est une droite
quand même vachement plus simple que ce
qu'on vous apprendre alors une droite
c'est quoi et bien en abscisse vous avez
la quantité d'énergie utilisée par les
hommes c'est à dire le parc de machines
en services et en ordonnée vous avez la
contrepartie monétaire du flux de
transformation physique c'est-à-dire les
euros depuis que j'ai commencé à
regarder cette courbe ses droits quand
c'était droit il ya dix ans c'est
toujours douce ça change pas tellement
c'est une autre manière de dire que
aujourd'hui le meilleur déterminant de
ce qu'est le pib s'est pas le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires djebbour quoi
tous ces trucs là n'ont strictement
aucune espèce d'importance
ce qui compte c'est la quantité de
machines en service c'est le seul truc
qui compte évidemment le fait que ces
machines puissent est alimenté en source
et comme l'essentiel de l'énergie qu'on
utilise sur terre et fossiles voici le
drame des négociateurs climat c'est que
le pib est aussi au premier ordre une
fonction linéaire des émissions de co2
donc contracté rapidement les émissions
de co2 s'est contracté rapidement le pib
et c'est la raison pour laquelle rien
avance sur le front du climat
parce que nous sommes en conflit
d'objectif permanent entre l'économie et
la préservation de l'environnement et à
chaque fois on arbitre en faveur de
l'économie du reste c'est à ça qu'on
peut trouver ça qu'on vous forme
donc je reprends très rapidement ce que
je viens de dire
on a des ressources naturelles dont des
combustibles fossiles qui comme toutes
les ressources naturelles sont gratuits
les ressources des combustibles fossiles
ayant été formés par 50 à 400 millions
d'années d'action de la mère nature
c'est gratuit exactement comme le reste
personne dans cette salle n'a payé le
moindre centime et personne nulle part
sur terre n'a payé le moindre centime
pour que le pétrole se forme d'accord le
pétrole apparaît sous terre gratuitement
ils seront 50 à 400 millions d'années
mais c'est gratuit ça permet d'alimenter
de la combustion donc des machines de
tous transformés par ailleurs ça a donc
permis ces machines d'augmenter
considérablement la productivité des
hommes parce que au fur et à mesure que
chaque homme était doté de plus en plus
de machines ça augmentait la quantité de
produits faits par cet ensemble mais au
dénominateur on continue à ne compter
que les hommes dire que la productivité
du travail au dénominateur vous mettez
pas sommes plus machine vous continuez à
mettre juste les hommes et donc vous
avez l'impression que la productivité
des hommes augmentent mais non ce qui
augmente c'est la production le fait que
la puissance totale sommes plus machines
augmente
oui vous et puis on vous a pas greffé
quarante trois paires de bras et 52
paires de gens même si laurent alexandre
en rêve
ce qui est arrivé c'est que on vous a
adjoint des machines et que ces machines
travaillent pour vous donc la
productivité du travail aujourd'hui à
les compter de travers parce qu
dénominateur on ne met pas la totalité
de ce qu'il produit en fait on ne met
qu'une toute petite partie de ce qui
produit c'est-à-dire les hommes
grâce à cette productivité nous avons
fait les 35 heures les six semaines de
congés payés les études longues
donc si à l'époque où il ya l'énergie
étaient rares et chères vous seriez pas
vous n'auriez pas été dans cet amphi
vous seriez éreinté à cette heure ci
après avoir passé la journée à ramasser
des patates très exactement ça que vous
feriez vous êtes des enfants de
l'énergie abondante comme moi du reste
je suis un enfant de l'énergie abondante
les gens en ville de l'énergie abondante
80 % d'emplois dans le tertiaire de
l'énergie abondante parce que les
machines produisent à notre place et
produisent tellement ils font des flux
tellement compliqué qu'on peut mettre 80
% des gens dans un bureau pour gérer ces
flux
enfin pas tout à fait dans un bureau il
ya aussi des vendeurs de supermarchés
etc mais on peut mettre 80 % des gens à
gérer les flux les états unis ont 80 %
d'emplois dans le tertiaire alors qu'ils
consomment considérablement plus
d'énergie que l'inde par exemple qui a
beaucoup moins d'emplois dans le
tertiaire donc plus un pays consomme
d'énergie plus là d'emplois dans le
tertiaire la dématérialisation de
l'économie ne se mesure absolument pas
au nombre de gens dans le tertiaire
c'est exactement l'inversé
plus il ya de gens dans tertiaire +
l'économie et matériels dans un monde
dématérialisé on retournera transpirer
on sera pas dans un bureau ça a fait les
voyages longs etc
le fait d'aller à bratislava pour passer
son temps et a deux dents dans ce que je
vous raconte là donc il ya deux sujets
de préoccupation on va dire qu' en ce
moment on mobilise un peu la tension les
y en a plein d'autres biodiversité le
fait que la teneur en cuivre du minerai
est passé de 14 % à 0 5 % en l'espace de
deux siècles enfin bref tout un tas de
trucs quand on pourrait discuter très
rapidement en deux éléments un sur le
changement climatique qui est la
conséquence du déversoir aval de cette
affaire sur le fait que l'on met le co2
dans l'air aussi dire que l'atmosphère
est une grande poubelle et à la bombe il
ya un goulet d'étranglement qui est
celui sur la quantité d'énergie
disponible alors très rapidement sur
l'amont joue un petit rappel de maths
comme il faut 50 à 400 millions d'années
pour que les combustibles fossiles se
forme on peut considérer qu aux échelles
de temps qui nous intéresse il y en a
une quantité donnée une fois pour toute
quand vous tapez dans une quantité
donnée une fois pour toutes
les mathématiques vous interdise de
pouvoir extraire chaque année plus que
l'année précédente
jusqu'à la nuit des temps d'accord avec
moi c'est juste pas possible c'est même
pas possible d'extraire chaque année la
même quantité que l'année précédente et
pour la nuit des temps en fait les
mathématiques vous impose qu'en pareil
cas vous
avoir un maximum absolu à l'extraction
et un déclin derrière alors ça ça vaut
pour le pétrole mais ça vaut pour le
cuivre ça vaut pour le tungstène ça vaut
pour le vanadium ça vaut pour le chrome
ça vaut pour le nickel en rsa vaut pour
tout ce qu'on sort de la croûte
terrestre et on a coutume d'appeler le
maximum
le pic alors maintenant j'ai une petite
question pour les gens dans cette salle
qui a déjà vu ce document 6 7 8
allez on va dire 10 en or de vendeurs
alors ce document est un rapport qui a
été sorti par l' agence internationale
de l'énergie en décembre 2018 et je vous
laisse lire la phrase en rouge puisque
vous êtes des anglicistes distinguer ici
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
vous dis que si vous excluez le pétrole
de roche-mère qu'on appelle le pétrole
de schiste
improprement aux états unis et les
sables bitumineux au canada là vous
savez les trucs les anciennes mis le feu
les mines à ciel ouvert
la production de pétrole dans le monde a
passé son maximum il y à 12 ans c'est à
dire en 2008 qui était au courant y
compris l'année bon c'est le truc
important à savoir en ce qui concerne
l'énergie et c'est le truc qui va
interdire que la croissance revienne de
manière structurelle en europe
je vous dis on peut à force de
quantitative easing faire des trucs et
des machins pendant un petit moment mais
vous avez ici une courbe qui est la
conséquence de ce que je viens de vous
raconter comme c'est l'énergie qui
pilote qui est de facteurs limitants de
l'économie le premier facteur limitant
de l'économie vous avez là quelque chose
qui en est la traduction logique la
courbe rouge représente la variation de
la quantité de pétrole qui sort de terre
chaque année ici à dire la quantité la
courbe bleue vous représente la
variation du pib par personne sur terre
je ne connais aucun modèle
macroéconomique qui vous reproduisent
les variations du pib par personne sur
trente ans aucun j'en connais un c'est
quand vous regardez la variation de la
quantité de pétrole qui sort de terre
celui-là marche extrêmement bien
et il marche extrêmement bien parce que
au sein de toutes les énergies qu'on
utilise le pétrole est la plus
limitantes d énergie parce qu'elles
pilotent les transports et que les
transports pilotes les échanges et donc
la capacité de chaque maillon
constitutive de l'économie a échangé
physiquement avec ce qui se passe avant
est ce qui se passe après donc la
production mondiale de pétrole
aujourd'hui malgré tout ce qu'on se
raconte sur les panneaux solaires et les
éoliennes c'est le truc qui pilote la
variation du pib
d'accord le truc qui pilote la variation
du pib là dedans vous constaterez que
les charges sociales ont changé les taux
de prélèvements obligatoires ont changé
loach terre mais par contre ce qui n'a
pas changé c'est la variation du pib par
personne suis très exactement la
variation de la quantité de pétrole
disponible par personne et vous voyez
quand il ya un décalage c'est le pétrole
qui varient avant le pib donc c'est pas
parce qu'on est plus riches parce que le
pib vient de mars qu'on achète plus de
pétrole
c'est parce qu'on a plus d'énergie on
met plus de machines en fonctionnement
donc ça transforme plus le monde et donc
la contrepartie monétaire de cette
transformation s'est plus de pib c'est
bien en ce sens là que ça va alors par
ailleurs cette quantité d'énergie
croissante qu'on utilise a conduit à des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
croissante alors à gaz à effet de serre
là aussi une petite définition en
passant c'est un gaz qui a la capacité
d'absorber les infrarouges terrestre
c'est ça la définition de gaz à effet de
serre c'est assez précis cédés gaz qui
sont connues depuis un siècle et demi là
dedans vous avez tous les gaz en gros
qui comporte trois atomes ou plus à
commencer par la vapeur d'eau et co2
alors la vapeur d'eau les hommes modifie
pas la quantité dans l'atmosphère y
arrive pas par contre le co2 size y
arrive donc dans les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre vous allez trouver le
dioxyde de carbone qui vient du charbon
celui qui vient du pétrole celui qui
vient du gaz au dessus celui qui vient
de la fabrication du ciment que vous
avez là encore au dessus celui qui vient
de la déforestation
après vous allez trouver une autre
molécule qui s'appelle du méthane qui
vient de tout un tas d'autres choses
notamment de l'élevage et l'exploitation
des hydrocarbures et enfin encore au
dessus vous avez d'autres gaz protoxyde
d'azoté et fluides frigorigènes
essentiellement alors regardez cette
courbe mais et trouvez moi le début de
la dématérialisation
alors le début de la dématérialisation
dans les discours il est là on a
dématérialisé parce qu'on a mis du
numérique et du digital partout
et parce qu'on a mis les gens dans des
bureaux bon très bien
la courbe d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mondiales n'en vois absolument
aucune trace et elle a raison parce que
l'ordinateur que je suis en train
d'utiliser là c'est une tonne et demie
de co2 donc la digitalisation ne permet
absolument pas d'éviter des émissions de
co2 en fait ça en a rajouté par rapport
à l'époque du papier les négociations
climat pour le moment ne sont pas des
négociations c'est des réunions climat
en cause ici vous avez la quantité de
co2 dans l'atmosphère depuis l'année de
ma naissance
alors c'est pas moi qui ai commandé la
série c'est juste que celle que j'ai
trouvé sur internet
coïncidence c'est chez les américains là
débute l'année ça vous voyez quand je
suis né il y avait un peu moins de 300
parties par million trois cent
millionième de co2 dans l'atmosphère
au moment où on se parle en ce moment on
n'est pas très loin de 420 soit dit en
passant
et vous voyez que ça augmente gentiment
tous les hauts rangs et de façon
extrêmement régulière et là dessus vous
pouvez placer alors ce que vous voulez
vous pouvez placer la dématérialisation
pouvez placer discours de chirac
ce que vous voulez en gros strictement
aucun événement vous allez placer dessus
n'a eu d'importance puisque ça n'a
jamais changé le cours des choses
derrière
donc vous voyez la première réunion de
la convention climat n'a rien changé à
ce qui s'est passé derrière
oui la manière dont ça a évolué avant et
la manière dont ça a évolué après soit
dit en passant c'est une réunion qui
s'est passé à bonn avec à l'époque une
mise de l'environnement qui s'appelait
angela merkel ça c'est protocole de
kyoto qui ne change rien à ce qui se
passe derrière ça c'est le gros échec de
copenhague
ah bon si on veut tu changes ni plus ni
moins et ça c'est le gros succès de
paris ah bon ça ne change ni plus ni
moins
donc aujourd'hui ce qui se passe dans
les réunions climat les fameuses coop
n'a strictement aucune espèce
d'importance sur l'évolution de la
concentration en co2 dans le monde alors
on y reviendra peut-être au moment du
débat il ya une raison à ça c'est que
les processus onusien n'ont pas la
capacité à infléchir ce qui se passe
dans le monde
en tout cas pas celui là l'onu est un
endroit où les gens entérine ce qui sont
déjà prêts à faire mais ça ne les oblige
pas à faire des choses nouvelles
l'eau qui viennent puis 10 bois voilà
qui est en train de faire ça va très
bien merci monsieur très sympa
l'année prochaine le co2 tomber dans
l'air alors là on va oublier la physique
et oublier les maths en faire un peu de
chimie je suis désolé je vous en cuisine
vraiment le co2 qu'on met dans l'air
vous savez que son non orthodoxes et
dioxyde de carbone alors dioxyde de
carbone ça veut donc dire que c'est un
oxyde il se trouve que les oxydes c'est
la chimie le veux sont des molécules qui
sont éternels tant qu'elles ne sont pas
agresser par quelque chose
dit autrement tant que vous leur
fournissez pas de l'énergie les oxydes
sont des molécules éternelle par exemple
le faire depuis qu'il ya de l'oxygène
sur terre l'oxygène à oxyder le faire et
le faire se trouve sous forme d'oxydé de
fer
et puis il reste sous forme de kits de
faire et ça fait des centaines de
millions d'années qu'il est là sous
forme d'oxydé de fer
ce qui veut dire que le co2 une fois
qu'on met dans l'atmosphère il n'a pas
de processus spontanée d'épuration de
l'atmosphère
il en a pas d'accord donc si il ne se
passe rien au contact de la terre où il
se passe des choses à voir et bien il
resterait éternellement dans
l'atmosphère alors il ya quand même des
choses qui se passent au contact de la
surface l'espace deux choses la première
c'est qu'une partie du co2 peut se
dissoudre dans l'océan mais c'est un
phénomène de vases communicants sert
s'il ya moins de co2 dans l'océan que
dans l'atmosphère ce qu'on appelle une
pression partiel inférieur le co2 passe
de l'un dans l'autre il pousse un peu
mais c'est un phénomène réversible si un
jour on retire du co2 de l'atmosphère à
ce moment là le co2 qui dans l'océan
ressortira pour se recoller dans
l'atmosphère c'est un phénomène de vases
communicants
et puis vous avez un deuxième processus
de soustraction c'est la photosynthèse
mais pour ça il faut un photon sert de
l'énergie et à ce moment vous avez
soustraction du co2 de l'atmosphère pour
entre guillemets nourrir une plante mais
la plante ne marche que si il y à de la
lumière du soleil ou dans un placard
ça dépend de la plante mais sans lumière
ça fonctionne pas alors à cause des ces
deux processus sont des processus au
contact de la surface il n'opère pas
dans l'atmosphère à cause du fait donc
le mollet que l'oxydé de dioxyde de
carbone pardon est une molécule très
stable
ça veut dire que quand on met du co2
dans l'atmosphère est bien ce co2 ne
s'en va pas vite et il s'en va même très
lentement si demain matin on arrêtait
les émissions humaines de co2 si demain
matin on les arrêter
aujourd'hui nous avons créé un surplus
je voulais montrer au graphique
précédent la voyez on était quand je
suis né à 320 on est aujourd'hui à 420
est en fait avant que les hommes fassent
les zazous avec le charbon on était à 2
181 et bien le fait de passer de 280 à
400 créé un surplus est bien ce surplus
si demain matin j'arrête les émissions
dans un siècle dont vous serez mort et
moi aussi
il y en aura encore 40% qui sera au
dessus de la tête de nos descendants
dans un millier d'années il y en aura
encore 20% qui sera au dessus de la tête
de nos descendants
et dans dix mille ans il y en aura
encore 10% qui sera au dessus de la tête
de nos descendants s'il ya des
descendants à ce moment là je vais vous
le dire autrement le climat dans lequel
je suis né il est perdu à jamais le
climat d'aujourd'hui parce que la dérive
climatique va continuer et perdu à
jamais or il n'ya pas de réversibilité
dans le processus du changement
climatique il n'y en a aucune
aucune aucune non tout ce qu'on peut
faire en ce qui concerne le changement
climatique
c'est de limiter la dérive futur mais de
toute façon à quelques moments qu'on
commence à agir
on est incapable de remettre en état le
système climatique dans l'état dans
lequel on l'a trouvé en entrant comme
dans les toilettes là on peut plus c'est
terminé
ce que vous voyez à ce moment également
sur ses graphiques c'est que tout ça se
gère enfin ou plus exactement concernent
des pâtes tant qu'ils sont extrêmement
longs alors que nous avons tout fait
dans le monde qui nous entoure pour
gérer la société sur des pattes temps
extrêmement court
alors vous rigoler avec macron mais vous
vous êtes en train d'apprendre à faire
des comptes trimestriels et du trading
en continu c'est bien pire
c'est bien pire ça pour raccourcir les
échéances de temps on peut pas faire
mieux
une société cotée en bourse sa stratégie
de long terme ces trois ans les bonnes
années six mois les mauvaises et tout ce
qui est
en continu j'ai envie de dire créer de
l'instantanéité qui nous masquer
totalement les enjeux de moyen et de
long terme et la concurrence libre et
non faussée a aussi de même effet sa
raccourci d horizon de temps donc on a
un vrai problème
on a organisé toute la société comme si
le monde était infini et soit dit en
passant une bonne partie de ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui en france et on a copié
les américains qui vivent effectivement
dans un pays qui se rapproche un peu
plus de l'infini que le nôtre et on a
énormément de mécanismes de schémas
mentaux à revoir dans cette affaire
parce qu'ils ne sont absolument pas
adapté aux défis de demain pour vous
montrer à quel point défis de demain est
pas un tout petit défi donc maintenant
je vais vous montrer très très
rapidement ce de quoi on parle quand on
parle de quelques degrés de variation
vous avez ici les écosystèmes qui
étaient installés en europe à la fin du
xxème siècle depuis le temps je mens de
cette carte laisser actuelle mais en
fait c'est pas actuelle s'est déjà passé
donc à la fin du xxème siècle si vous
fichez la paix aux forêts elle ne craint
pas trop elle ne se dessèche pas trop et
vous avez des grosses espèces végétales
c'est à dire des arbres ça veut dire
qu'il pleut assez et que il fait ni trop
froid ni trop chaud ici vous avez
l'europe ya vingt mille ans donc je
voulais dit tout à l'heure il ya vingt
mille ans le climat a été très différent
il a considérablement changé jusqu'à il
ya dix mille ans et l'europe ya vingt
mille on est au coeur de la dernière ère
glaciaire donc il fait plus froid que
maintenant la sidèrent le dictionnaire
est bien fait aussi c'est qu'il fait
plus froid alors la première chose que
vous voyez c'est que erasmus en suède
vous oubliez et en laponie aussi parce
que ya pas de suédois il n'y a pas de
l'ap ont la cop16 à glasgow vous oubliez
ya pas de glasgow
il n'y a pas de whisky migros
catastrophe parce qu'à pas d'écossais
vous voyez que tous ces braves gens sont
sous des glaciers extrêmement hipay qui
se consomme constitué à ce moment là et
vous n'avez pas non plus de québécois ni
tous les autres canadiens du reste parce
que le canada est aussi sous trois
kilomètres de glace pour faire ce très
très gros glaçon posé sur le nord de
l'europe et ce très très gros glaçon
opposés sur le canada est le fait que le
groenland et l'antarctique ont un peu
grossi il a fallu prendre de l'eau
quelque part cet os a été prise dans
l'océan et comme l'océan est une grande
baignoire dont le fonds n'a pas bougé et
bien le niveau de l'océan est beaucoup
plus bas donc il n'y a pas de club de
voile qui va en revanche à hec voit la
méditerranée si vous voulez enfin
naviguer en méditerranée c'est pas drôle
pat club de voile sur la manche puis a
pas de manche
vous n'avez pas de paradis fiscaux dans
les angles d'un manque pas dans le monde
le climat étant beaucoup plus sec
il est beaucoup plus froid pardon il est
beaucoup plus sec parce que quand il ya
il fait plus froid ça c'est pas beau -
l'eau et donc il ya moins de
précipitation et dans ce climat sec et
froid et bien voyez vous n'avez pas
beaucoup de français puisque la totalité
de la population française que l'on peut
nourrir avec des airelles et des
mammouths représentent les effectifs
salariés d'une petite multinationale
fond d'une moyenne multinationales on va
dire quand l'europe est passée de cet
état là à cet état là manifestement ça
c'est inscrit dans le cadre d'une
planète qui s'est réchauffé c'est
parfois dit le réchauffement planétaire
qui a piloté cette évolution pour le
continent européen
c'est 5 degrés en cinq à dix mille ans
donc là vous avez soulevé une expérience
grandeur nature qui a été fait par la
planète sur une transition climatique de
quelques degrés et vous voyez le
bouleversement environnementale que ça
introduit alors sans rentrer dans le
détail des conséquences parce que je
suis déjà trop long je me limite après
la planche suivante
sans rentrer dans le détail des
conséquences il est absolument évident
que quatre degrés de hausse pour le
climat c'est au premier ordre
la barbarie partout c'est la barbarie
partout parce que ça va représenter une
telle déstabilisation des conditions
auxquelles nous avons été habitués de ma
de manière enfin localement depuis des
milliers d'années que nous serons
incapables ou surplus dans un monde à
l'énergie qui deviendra plus rare c'est
à dire aux moyens d'adaptation et de
faire face aux envies aux ennuis qui
deviendront plus limité nous serons
incapables de résister ça dans la joie
et la bonne humeur et des systèmes
garantissant les libertés individuelles
comme aujourd'hui on aura des problèmes
d'accès à la nourriture on aura des
problèmes d'accès à l'eau on aura des
problèmes d'accès aux bois on aura des
problèmes d'accès à des environnements
stable etc
c'est absolument évident que dans ce
genre de contexte nous redeviendrons des
guerriers donc quand on lutte pour la
limite de la dérive climatique
on lutte effectivement pour la paix
c'était pas une figure de style que
d'avoir donné de prix nobel de la paix
au giec s'est pas complètement stupide
il s'agit bien effectivement de ne pas
avoir une déstabilisation massive de ce
qui nous entoure
une des choses qu'il faut garder en tête
soit dit en passant dans cette affaire
c'est de se défier de l'illusion de la
linéarité ckoi l'illusion de la
linéarité ses seuls à laquelle on est
très très habitué dans nos systèmes
comptables c'est de penser que une cause
quatre fois plus importante va faire des
dégâts qui sont juste quatre fois plus
grave alors sur l'élévation de
température ça veut dire une élévation
de température de 4 degrés c'est quatre
fois plus grave qu'une élévation de
température de 20° que nous avons déjà
connu et ben on transpire un peu de
temps en temps et à trois forêts qui
crament mais quand même c'est pas très
grave
alors en fait c'est pas vrai du tout et
pour vous pour comprendre que ce que en
fait c'est pas du tout comme ça qu'il
faut raisonner sur des systèmes non
linéaire et le climat est un système non
hier je vais prendre un autre système
non linéaire qui votent propre corps si
vous avez votre température interne qui
augmente de 20 degrés vous fait faire un
bond excuses vous n'allez pas en cours
et tout se passe bien
si votre température interne augmentent
de 5 degrés vous ratez pas cinq jours de
cours vous êtes mort donc enfin de fait
vous allez rater cinq jours de cours et
même un peu plus c'est exactement pareil
en ce qui concerne le climat
donc 4 degrés de hausse et pas quatre
fois plus grave que 1° c'était un
million de fois plus grave on ne sait
pas exactement aujourd'hui juste pour
garder un autre élément en tête dans un
rapport que le giec a rendu il ya
quelques mois sur changement climatique
et r il y avait un graphique qui disait
qu'à partir de trois degrés de hausse
on considère qu' il y aura de
l'insécurité alimentaire généralisée sur
la planète et vous vous rappelez que les
déclencheurs des révolutions c'est
toujours quand les gens apparemment j'ai
alors si on veut se limiter et je vais
finir avec ça à 2 degrés de hausse qui
aujourd'hui l'objectif politique qu'on
s'est donné c'est un objectif politique
parce que pourquoi deux plutôt que 2,1
1,8 3,2 il ya une deuxième droite qu'il
faut avoir en tête donc une première
droite qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est
nrj pib et une deuxième droite qu'il
faut avoir en tête ces élévations de
température émissions totales entre 1850
et 2100 donc en fait ce graphique
représente un truc assez simple c'est
une superposition de simulation
une droite là vous avez la quantité
totale de co2 qu'on va mettre dans
l'atmosphère entre 1850 et 2100 peu
importe qu'on le mette au début à la fin
et sert pas d'importance et ici vous
avez la réponse en température du
système climatique entre 1850 et 2100
alors pour parler de choses récentes
afin 2018 on avait mis deux mille deux
cent cinquante milliards de tonnes de
co2 dans l'atmosphère et donc nous avons
signé pour 1,5 degrés de réchauffement
j'arrête les émissions tout de suite là
de toute façon on tape les 5 degrés donc
aujourd'hui l'objectif de 1,5 degré il
est mort il est devenu inatteignable et
donc quand je vois nokia qui dit qu'ils
sont 1 5 degré compliant comme disait
coluche je me barre c'est grand
n'importe quoi
ils peuvent pas être complaisantes d'un
truc qui n'arrivera jamais mais il ya
des tas de services comme qui sont très
très bon pour faire du bullshit dans ce
domaine
si si on veut se limiter à 2 degrés à ce
moment nous avons droit à trois mille
milliards de tonnes de co2 nous
collectivement les humains dont 2250 ont
déjà été émis dépenser d'accord donc on
a un capital de 3000 et on a déjà bouffé
2250 alors comme vous allez faire une
division comme moi où tu seras actions
d'abord une division ensuite ça veut
dire qu'ils noueraient 750 milliards de
tonnes à émettre
c'est pile deux tiers de 2250 donc ça
veut dire que l'humanité prises
collectivement peut encore pour le
siècle qui vient voir les 80 ans mais on
va dire le siècle et mettre le tiers de
ce qui a été émis dans le siècle qui
vient de s'écouler
c'est ça que je veux dire l'objectif des
deux degrés et comme on sera en moyenne
trois fois plus nombreux pendant cette
période qui s'ouvre
ça veut dire que chaque individu pris
individuellement a droit au 9e du co2
qu'un individu qui meurent aujourd'hui a
émis pendant sa vie c'est ça que ça veut
dire
donc en gros les enfants qui naissent
aujourd'hui ont le droit au 9e de ce à
quoi ont eu droit à leurs grands-parents
qui meurent aujourd'hui c'est ça les
deux degrés si je le dis en termes de
dynamique
ça veut dire que d'ici à ce que vous
ayez mon âge il faut que les émissions
planétaires soit divisée par 3 alors
comme excellent sait faire les intérêts
composés et puis il ya des futurs
banquiers dans cette salle qui sauront
faire ça très bien aussi une division
par trois en trente ans c'est en gros 4
% de baisse par an donc ça veut dire qu
un monde qui est de degré et donc une
société qui est de degré est un monde
qui est capable enfin de s'organiser
pour que les émissions de co2 baisse de
4% par an à partir de demain matin
est une société qui est de degré parce
que les d'état de société qui se
revendique tête 2 degrés est une société
qui est capable de survivre
économiquement dans ce monde là sous la
forme sous laquelle elle est organisée
aujourd'hui à priori il y en a très
exactement dans le monde 0-1 qui a pas
une société aujourd'hui qui est capable
de survivre
enfin de faire exactement le même
chiffre d'affaires et même résultat dans
un monde dans lequel les émissions se
mettent à baisser de 4% par an c'est
évident que non voilà j'ai été un peu
long et alors maintenant je crois que il
faut qu'on passe aux questions que c'est
ça
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur jancovici pour votre
présentation
j'aimerais dans un premier toit en
revenir sur vous avez parlé du pic pour
le pétrole en particulier
j'aimerais demander si une
décarbonisation de l'énergie de grande
ampleur est envisageable d'ici 2050
en particulier il ya la question des
énergies renouvelables sont elles une
réelle solution est également le
nucléaire dans sa forme actuelle est il
durable alors sur les énergies
renouvelables ce que j'ai montré tout à
l'heure c'est qu'en fait c'est des
énergies dont on sort
historiquement les hommes ont utilisé du
bois la force de l'eau la force du vent
et le fait que l'on se soit mis à
utiliser des énergies fossiles
on l'a fait parce que ça permettait
d'avoir de beaucoup plus grande quantité
des deux blocs pardon beaucoup plus de
puissance c'est-à-dire beaucoup beaucoup
d'énergie en peu de temps ce que les
énergies renouvelables diffuse en
particulier le vent et le soleil ne
permettait pas d'avoir aujourd'hui
rebasculer sur les énergies
renouvelables est possible pour quelques
happy few dans le monde
alors si vous êtes norvégien que vous
êtes 4,5 millions d'habitants sur un
territoire qui doit faire quoi le tiers
de la france à peu près essentiellement
montagneux vous pouvez rêver de
consommer quatre fois l'électricité d'un
français et en plus ce qu'elle soit 100%
aux nerfs il ya strictement aucun
problème mais ils sont quatre millions
et demi si vous êtes belge c'est plus
compliqué parce que quantité de montagne
dans le plat pays de monsieur bart elle
est un peu limité et donc pour faire des
barrages c'est pas simple si vous voulez
faire appel au vent il faut des grandes
surfaces parce qu'il faut brasser sans
mauvais jeu de mots de grandes quantités
d'air par ailleurs il faut de très
grandes quantités de métal il faut de 50
n'ont pas tout à fait ouais c'est ça il
faut quelques dizaines de fois plus de
métal par kilowattheure produit quand
vous utilisez des éoliennes que quand
vous utilisez des dispositifs
centralisée qu'il soit gaz à charbon ou
nucléaires donc quand vous voulez
repasser aux énergies renouvelables
vous aller buter soit sur un problème
d'utilisation des sols pour avoir des
grandes quantités de bois il faut avoir
des grandes quantités de forêt est donc
un pays avec beaucoup de forêts et peu
d'habitants ça ce cas de la suède par
exemple la suède ces neuf millions
d'habitants sur 350 mille kilomètres
carrés
dire les deux tiers du territoire
français et 70 % de forêts sur ce
territoire bon oeil peuvent
effectivement faire tourner leur
industrie à la biomasse se chauffer à la
biomasse ça pose pas de problème à
nouveau quand vous êtes en belgique pays
danse est toute petite forêt vous
oubliez ça marche pas donc la biomasse
demande beaucoup d espace
l'hydroélectricité demande beaucoup de
montagne le vent est une énergie
extrêmement diffuse donc collecter
l'énergie du vent on demande énormément
de moyens matériels des métaux du béton
etc et le soleil c'est exactement pareil
c'est une énergie très diffuse donc
collecté beaucoup d'énergie du soleil ça
demande beaucoup de métaux beaucoup d
espace et c'est donc les énergies
renouvelables ma conclusion c'est que
malheureusement nous n'arriverons pas et
en particulier pas dans les 30 ans qui
viennent et même pas plus tard à garder
le même niveau de consommation
énergétique globale avec uniquement des
énergies renouvelables à 8 milliards sur
terre ça passe pas donc si on redescend
à 50 millions d'habitants sur terre
probablement que ça peut se gérer à 8
milliards sur terre c'est totalement
inenvisageable
avec le genre de niveau de vie que on
les terriens aujourd'hui si on accepte
de diviser de pouvoir d'achat par dix
enfin ou si on est obligé tous de
diviser notre pouvoir d'achat par 10 ou
on pourra probablement revenir aux
énergies renouvelables mais en gros
c'est ça la contrepartie d'un retour aux
énergies renouvelables
c'est pour ça qu'en gros aujourd'hui on
est dans une dans un paradigme un peu
désagréable qui est ou bien on se dit on
profite de la fête qui peut pas être
totalement renouvelable tant que ça dure
et puis après on verra bien ou bien on
se dit non on va y aller à des trucs
renouvelables et au nucléaire réunira
près mais à ce moment même avec le
nucléaire ça veut dire se serrer la
ceinture alors le nucléaire c'est
quelque chose qui est un peu différent
sud énergies bas carbone c'est pas une
énergie renouvelable
c'est une énergie qui utilisent la
propriété qu'à un métal parce que
l'uranium est un métal donc ce n'est pas
une énergie fossile c'est un métal
c'est disponible en quantité limitée
mais c'est pas une énergie fossile un
métal le noyau d'un métal de se casser
en deux en libérant de l'énergie quand
on lui fait quand on lui fait une
indigestion de neutrons ce cette énergie
nucléaire est une énergie récentes comme
le photovoltaïque soit dit en passant
qui représentent aujourd'hui 10% de
l'électricité dans le monde
enfin un peu un gros 10% d'électricité
dans le monde donc on va dire 1 2% ou 3%
de la quantité totale d'énergie qu'on
consomme dans le monde donc c'est pas
beaucoup
ce qui veut dire que dès les 30 ans qui
viennent ça peut pas faire la totalité
du job non plus sa part de trop bas mais
c'est toujours bon à prendre de mon
point de vue donc si on a comme premier
et on y reverra problème en dans les
questions c'est l'un des sujets en
france il y en a quelques-uns pas
beaucoup mais celui là est assez
emblématique où il ya le plus grand
écart entre la perception du risque et
la réalité des faits donc c'est un
domaine assez intéressant pour faire en
tout cas quand on a envie de faire de la
sociologie c'est intéressant parce qu'il
ya vraiment un très très gros écarts
entre les deux le la bannière dont ton
donc tout ce qu'on peut faire est bon à
prendre
je redis à la fois pour les
renouvelables et pour le nucléaire quand
on n'a pas peur du nucléaire le
nucléaire est plus efficace que les
énergies renouvelables diffuse et
intermittente donc le vent et le soleil
parce que le vent et le soleil c'est pas
des systèmes complets si on ne devait
fonctionner qu'avec du vent et du soleil
il n'est pas complètement sûr que cette
conférence aura lieu ce soir parce que
pas de soleil c'est même la définition
de la nuit et s'il n'y a pas assez de
vent pour faire fonctionner à la fois
les lumières ici et l'hôpital et le
train et les ascenseurs de madame michu
qui habite au 10e étage etc
il n'était pas complètement sûr qu'en
face la conférence donc on aurait pu
mettre une affiche conférence sous
réserve qu'ils aient du vent
si on n'accepte pas ce genre de système
c'est à dire qu'on veut avoir une
électricité pilotable et donc avoir de
l'électricité quand on a décidé de faire
la conférence il faut compléter par des
dispositifs de stockage et à ce moment
quand on regarde la quantité de
matériaux et le prix d'un système
complet avec le stockage qui va avec
c'est toujours beaucoup plus cher de
faire des nerfs diffuse que de faire du
nucléaire
donc le ça demande beaucoup plus de
moyens donc le nucléaire est un truc
intéressant plus intéressant on va dire
que les oranais rediffuse mais ça ne
couvre que l'électricité pas ça fait pas
de chaleur par exemple comme le bois
donc tout ce qui est décarbonée est bon
à prendre mais en empilant le décarbonés
l'un sur l'autre
de toute façon les ordres de grandeurs
font qu' on ne peut pas rêver d'avoir la
quantité d'énergie que nous offre
aujourd'hui les combustibles fossiles
donc là le il ya trois pieds on va dire
dans la décarbonation à terme c'est la
sobriété à laquelle on sera de toute
façon contraints à jour puisque les
énergies fossiles sont épuisables façon
un jour on aura le pib qui sera
structurellement décroissant on a le
les énergies renouvelables et on a le
nucléaire et on est à mon avis il faut
jouer sur les trois vous nous expliquer
que donc on va nécessairement arriver à
une société où on aura une niveau de
production qui sera plus faible et ma
question c'est quelle sera la nature de
ce niveau de production
assistera-t-on par exemple un retour de
l'agriculture c'est ce que vous semblez
défendre est ce qu'on aura une économie
de la réparation
quel parent occuperont l'industrie les
transports et les autres différents
secteurs de l'économie selon vous et
aussi est ce que ce sera une production
qui sera davantage intensive on
travaille quand capitale quel type de
travail etc
alors c'est très difficile de répondre à
cette question parce que l'avenir ne va
pas être une répétition total du passé
entre les deux on a quand même augmenter
notre capital de connaissances et il ya
un certain nombre de choses qu'on sait
faire aujourd'hui qui sont pas
nécessairement des choses qui sont très
intensive en ressources qu'on conservera
normalement tant qu'on sera capables de
se parler et se transmettent le savoir
le si on est d'abord là là en europe
la bonne nouvelle c'est que cette
contraction de l'économie pour moi a
déjà commencé quand vous regardez
l'économie réelle c'est à dire les
tables les chaises les mètres carrés et
c'est le niveau de production annuelle
aujourd'hui est inférieur à ce qu'il
était en 2007
alors pourquoi je vous parle de 2007
parce qu'il se trouve qu'en 2006
l'europe est passée par un maximum
d'approvisionnement énergétique et qui
est le corollaire du pic de production
du pétrole conventionnel dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure
plus le corollaire de deux autres choses
qui est que le pic de production du
charbon en europe date des années 60
or le charbon est une énergie locale qui
voyage très peu donc quand une zone
commence à être en déclin sur sa
production charbonnière domestique c'est
très très rare que sa consommation de
charbon continuent d'augmenter fortement
pendant des décennies parce que le
charbon est un truc qui voyagent pas
très bien le donc en europe le charbon
est en déclin depuis les années 60 le
gaz est en déclin depuis 2005
alors c'est une coïncidence il se trouve
que le gaz voyagent moins bien que le
pétrole pour une raison très simple
c'est que le gaz et gazeux est donc dans
un mètre cube de gaz vous avez mille
fois moins d'énergie dans un net recul
de pétrole et donc la logistique du gaz
est quelque chose qui occasionne des
pertes énergétiques et donc des coûts
beaucoup plus important ce qui veut dire
que le gaz est une énergie qui passent
moins facilement les frontières et en
tout cas qui passe beaucoup moins
facilement les continents que le pétrole
or en 2005 la mer du nord qui à l'époque
fournissait 60% du gaz européen passe
son pic
donc depuis la production de la mer du
nord est en déclin donc depuis 2005 2006
le charbon est en déclin parce qu'il
était depuis les années 60
le gaz est en déclin à cause du déclin
de la mer du nord le pétrole est en
déclin à cause du déclin du
conventionnel dans le monde alors c'est
raconter un peu avec le challenge mais
pas tant ce qui veut dire que 75 % de
l'énergie européenne est en déclin le
nucléaire est en déclin parce que les
européens n'aiment pas ça et donc c'est
pas les éoliennes et les panneaux
solaires qui compense vraiment leur est
alors posée la question de la croissance
donc l'énergie est en déclin
le pib réel vrai industrielle est en
déclin depuis 2007
quand vous regardez le pib tout court
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
il est complété par tout un tas de
machins qui n'ont rien à y faire dont
notamment l'inflation des actifs qui
génère un pib virtuel c'est un artefact
comptable mais sinon le j'ai envie de
dire le pib vrai de l'europe n'augmente
plus depuis 2007 il est même en légère
contraction
à mon avis la prochaine marche
d'escalier soit dit en passant n'est pas
très très loin c'est à dire qu'on n'est
pas très très loin d'un nouvelle crise
nouvelle discontinuité
donc la réponse à votre question vous
l'avez déjà pour partie en regardant ce
qui se passe autour de vous
qu'est ce qu'il est en train de se
passer en ce moment en europe eh bien
vous voyez des gens à la périphérie des
villes qui ont de plus en plus de mal à
joindre les deux bouts
ça c'est un truc qui est logique pour
moi dans un monde qui commencent à
manquer d'énergie parce que c'est ces
gens là qui sont les plus marginaux dans
le fonctionnement du système et donc
c'est l'épreuve pour des tas de raisons
et donc c'est les premiers à être éjecté
quand ça commence à parler bien vous
voyez effectivement des jeunes urbains
qui commencent à revenir à la terre
alors ça fait d'être marginal
aujourd'hui mais que vous commencez en
voir quelques uns vous voyez
effectivement des phénomènes de partage
qui commence à se développer
la colocation est un phénomène de
partage l'absence de voitures chez une
partie des jeunes est un phénomène de
restriction qui est lié au fait que les
gens ont plus les moyens de s'en acheter
une
vous voyez également que tant qu'on a
une contraction des moyens avec par
ailleurs un système très libérale les
inégalités augmentent parce que dans un
système très libérale les plus agiles
continue à avoir la possibilité
et de récupérer à leur profit une
fraction croissante du gâteau et donc
vous voyez en même temps une phase une
fraction croissante des gens qui
souffrent à une faction et quelques
super riches qui sont de plus en plus
super riches
voilà donc vous êtes déjà en train
d'observer autour de vous les prémices
de ce qui va se passer après prévoir de
manière exacte
quels sont les types d'emplois etc alors
là c'est vraiment la boule de cristal
c'est beaucoup plus facile quand on fait
ce genre d'exercice de dire ce qui
n'arrivera pas que de dire ce qui
arrivera voilà donc je peux vous dire
qu'une île de france à 10 millions
d'habitants prospère pendant 50 ans ça
n'arrivera pas après et que à ce titre
par exemple avoir fait paris-saclay je
pense que c'est une avarie ben justement
sur les inégalités
donc il est clair que le déclin de la
croissance dont vous parlez socialement
il est difficile à accepter vous l'avez
reconnu d'ailleurs dans d'autres
conférences et donc s'agissant des
politiques sociales en particulier de de
lutte contre les inégalités est ce que
vous pensez que sont des alliés de notre
changement de modèle de notre changement
de paradigme ou au contraire parce qu
elles peuvent avoir de conséquence par
exemple plus de pouvoir d'achat plus de
consommation plus d'émissions mais en
même temps si on réoriente des richesses
qui sont concentrés dans la main de peu
de personnes vers des investissements
pour rénover des bâtiments pour avoir
des infrastructures qui sont moins
énergivores ou pour subventionner des
des emplois qui a priori serait pas
suffisant pour vivre mais qui en fait
pour et parce qu'ils sont durables
donnez enfin avoir des revenus plein et
permettre à des gens de vivre de manière
à consommer moins d'énergie ou à émettre
moins de carbone donc est-ce que vous
pensez que la lutte contre les
inégalités c'est compatible avec ce que
vous recherchez
il faut que ça le soit au sens où alors
c'est c'est très difficile de donner des
manipule dans cette affaire des termes
qui n'ont pas de définition normative
l'injustice ne se définit pas autrement
que par un sentiment d'injustice en tout
cas pour moi l'inégalité il ya des
définition normative par exemple sur les
revenus etc
après c'est aussi très dépendant de la
manière dont les gens ressentent la
situation dans laquelle ils sont il ya
un des associés il a une blague qui
consiste à dire le revenu minimum à qui
que ce soit qu'on pose la question c'est
ce que je gagne + 10 %
donc il ya une fille il ya un sentiment
perçu qui est qui et qui est très
important et par ailleurs le les crampes
les grands penseurs de la démocratie en
particulier deauville expliqué que le
sentiment d'injustice était
consubstantielle à la démocratie c'est
que tant que l'on vivait dans un système
démocratique les gens de toute façon se
plaindrait de leur sort et serait pas
content et alors tu as envie d'être vide
expliqué sa de la manière suivante il
expliqué qu' à partir du moment où tout
le monde avait les mêmes droits et les
mêmes libertés et donc on était tous
égaux sur la ligne de départ si on
n'était pas au même endroit sur la ligne
d'arrivée c'est que c'était pas juste
c'est assez bien vu je trouve donc il
faut que j'ai envie de dire la mise en
mouvement de la société soient
compatibles avec avec un sentiment de
moindre injustice dire je veux dire
comme ça cela étant une des grandes
injustices c'est déjà d'être privés
d'emploi donc le 6 si on a plus de gens
qui ont du travail avec des travaux qui
sa fin avec du travail qui est un peu
moins payés est-ce que j'ai augmenté les
inégalités ou est-ce que je les ai
baissé alors c'est bon donc on peut
avoir un long débat là dessus donc les
gens qui ont déjà un boulot vous diront
c'est pas juste et les gens qui n'ont
pas encore vous dire on sait très bien
le ce que je crois c'est que il est
essentiel de donner espoir alors ça
s'incarne notamment par le fait qu' on
est les idées à peu près clair sur
lagonda
il ya une petite expérience que je peux
vous citer à cette occasion il ya
quelques années bien faire une dizaine
maintenant j'avais été invité par une
branche de la cfdt à faire une
intervention
alors je leur avais dit à peu près la
même chose que ce soit qu'on allait tous
mourir je passais deux fois plus de
temps et je me suis dit à la fin des
joueurs a expliqué que le pib croît sans
forever on n'arrête pas ça il ya dix ans
j'étais pas très loin du moment où ça a
commencé à devenir une réalité
donc le je pensais que derrière j'allais
me faire sortir à grand coup de pied
dans le derrière et pas du tout en fait
ils ont été extrêmement intéressé à
discuter de concrètement ce qu'on
pouvait faire de sa part ou sens devront
s'en réjouit mais au sens du coup on
fait quoi
donc il ya un il ya un test qu'il faut
faire parce que pour le moment je n'ai
jamais vu faire qui est d'expliquer aux
gens pourquoi est-ce qu'on a des marges
de manoeuvre qui ne sont pas celles
qu'on avait hier et du coup de discuter
ensemble de ce qui est encore possible
dans ce genre de cadre et de ce qui ne
l'est pas je pense dit autrement que le
fait de comprendre ce qui se passe
quelque part est un élément
indispensable est un préalable
indispensable à des débats surtout
sentiment d'injustice parce que sinon je
vois pas trop comment est ce qu'on
arrive à avoir quelque chose qui
permette de voir la lumière au bout du
tunnel
justement je rebondis sur ce que vous
dites sur le fait que la démocratie
potentiellement elle est en danger en
tout cas on le ressent dans mon discours
et sur les tensions sociales
est ce que justement la convention
citoyenne pour le climat qui a été un
peu imposé à macron soit à l'époque doit
poser c'est lui qui l'a choisi il l'a
choisie mais parce qu'on lui a mis la
pression notamment serré le joey et
marion cotillard mais sur france inter
est-ce que c'est pas justement un bon
moyen de tester l'acceptabilité sociale
de ce dont on a besoin pour la
transition écologique en le faisant de
manière pédagogique que justement les
gens comme vous le disiez avec votre
intervention à la cfdt
ils se mettent d'accord en comprenant
que on a besoin de réduire de deux temps
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
ainsi peuvent se mettre d'accord et
c'est justement le l'objectif de la
convention est ce que vous y croyez
j'ai une lecture beaucoup plus cynique
que vous delà de cette histoire de
convention je pense que macron voit le
sujet environnement monte il le voit
tellement bien qu'il prend il prend une
première prise de guerre qui s'appelle
hulot qui met dans un ministère en se
disant comme ça les gens comprendront
que je suis un mec eco friendly
c'est pas un plaidoyer pour mâcon ce que
ça donne c'est pas un plaidoyer pour ma
créance que je faisais non mais je
voulais voir le sujet le sujet
environnement continue à monter hulot
fous l'camp
après ne rien avoir fait du reste parce
qu'il n'était pas fait pour être
ministre et ensuite macron se retrouve
un peu à poil et se dire qu'est ce que
je peux faire
et puis
seagate du temps donc la convention
citoyenne c'est une façon de gagner du
temps si macron avait une vision claire
de ce qu'il a envie de faire
s'il avait bien compris le problème est
un plan bien organisés pour y faire face
ils n'auraient pas besoin de convention
citoyenne ce qui pourrait faire c'est
des assemblées citoyennes pour tester
l'acceptabilité de mesures bien précises
donc il pourrait dire par exemple
j'envisage de remettre en service un
impôt à la détention des véhicules qui
croît fortement avec la consommation du
véhicule
ce que vous pensez que c'est une bonne
ou une mauvaise idée voilà qu'elle
conduise à un truc très précis mais dira
la convention citoyenne
vous allez à la place de mon
administration et de mon gouvernement
veut faire un projet de loi et des
projets de décret et le mandat c'est
baisser les émissions de 40%
sachant que je prends des gens qui au
début découvre le problème etc
c'est juste pas sérieux donc je suis pas
en train de dire que les gens sont pas
bien moi j'ai discuté avec quelques uns
d'entre eux je les tons formidable c'est
pas le sujet simplement ils le disent
eux-mêmes du reste ils sont assez
désemparé il partait d'un socle de
connaissances qui était très hétérogène
et pour l'essentiel d'entre eux ils ont
juste découvert le problème au moment où
ils ont été donnés du couple sont un peu
tombés de leur chaise et le lemay de
dire je vais remplacer une
administration je vais remplacer des
ministres je vais remplacer des moyens
d'études etc par 150 personnes tirées au
sort pour me faire le grand plan du tout
c'est quelque chose qui pour moi est
juste destinée à gagner du temps voilà
je suis désolé moi j'ai gagné d'énergie
allumez le machin parce que quand même
sinon vos sponsors engueuler et ça c'est
beaucoup plus grave que tout ce qu'on
peut faire par ailleurs
voilà c'est pas beau ça
ouf
le financement continuera d'arrivée est
absolument et c'est pas du tout cyril
dion j'ai pas qu'il y aurait mis la
pression il a décidé de il a piqué
l'idée mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il a tout à fait décidé de le faire
et il a tout à fait décidé de le faire
pour gagner du temps et par ailleurs il
devait avoir l'agenda des municipales en
tête donc il s'est dit voilà je vais
racheté un brevet de vertu pour essayer
de piquer trois électeurs est élevé et
je vais faire ce truc là je ne crois pas
une seconde qu'ils aient quoi que ce
soit de beaucoup plus réfléchie que ça
derrière ce votre cas du alors j'en
profite puisqu'on parle de politique il
ya quelque chose qui est très difficile
pour notre génération c'est que on va
vous écouter vous quand on veut
comprendre les sujets énergétiques
on va écouter d'autres personnes on va
écouter pablos erwin si on veut se faire
peur et par l'écologie mais on n'a aucun
leader politique c'est à dire que il ya
personne pour aller voter
personne nous propose enfin un modèle de
société qui soit vraiment à la hauteur
des enjeux
donc désolé de vous poser cette question
mais si jamais vous étiez conseiller
d'un président fraîchement élu que vous
étiez président ou même quels seraient
les principales actions que vous pensez
qu'il faudrait mettre en place ou que
vous mettrez en place
alors je vais je vais prendre les deux
questions de façon totalement séparées
parce que
je ne pense pas ce qu'à dieu ne plaise
et heureusement pour moi que je serai un
jour président de la république et je
n'ai aucune envie d'être conseiller d'un
président
dit autrement ou bien il a parfaitement
compris le problème
il a un plan cohérent il a pas besoin de
moi ou bien il a rien compris au
problème et j'ai surtout pas envie
d'être son conseiller
mais le mais je vais prendre le je vais
prendre la première question qui et
comment est ce qu'on arrive à faire
émerger une offre politique dans le
contexte dans lequel on est parce que je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous moi
je ne vois pas d'offre politique
correspondant à une vision un peu
pragmatique des choses il ya deux
manières de répondre à la question
la première c'est une réponse un peu al
anglaise
c'est à dire le consensus devient
tellement important au sein de la
population que finalement peu importe
qui est là il va faire des choses qui
sont pas idiote
tout simplement parce que la population
le veut alors en angleterre par exemple
il ya un consensus très fort pour
décarbonés la production électrique et
bien que vous ayez les travaillistes les
conservateurs le machin etc
boris johnson et sa coupe de cheveux un
on s'en fout de toute façon ils vont
continuer d'avancer dans la même
direction
et ils vont faire ce qu'il faut pour
décarbonés la production électrique le à
ce moment vous vous avez résolu le
problème j'ai envie de dire par défaut
il ya pas besoin d'un leader parce que
de toute façon ils vont tous faire la
même chose si vous voyez les choses un
peu plus à la française où on est quand
même dans un état qui est beaucoup plus
dirigiste je pense comme vous qu'il faut
quelqu'un qui porte une offre qui
correspond en gros à une façon
d'attaquer le d'attaquer le problème au
mieux
j'ai envie de dire je ne sais pas d'où
ça peut venir aujourd'hui le très très
honnêtement je suis aussi désemparé vous
parce que je vois pas que vous alliez
d'un coup d'un bout à l'autre de
l'échiquier il ya personne qui
correspondent vraiment à ce genre de
choses parce que les débats
environnementaux en france se sont
structurées de façon à économique
jusqu'à maintenant c'est là qu'ils se
sont toujours structuré à côté de
l'économie
alors je dis pas qu'il faut invoquer
l'économie comme raison d'agir ça je
pense que l'économie est une très
mauvaise raison d'agir
je pense que sur ce genre de sujet il
faut agir parce qu'on pense que la paix
c'est quelque chose qui est plus
important que l'économie d'une certaine
manière
par contre ce que je crois c'est qu'une
fois qu'on a décidé d'agir
il faut agir en ayant l'efficacité
maximale des moyens qu'on décide
d'affecter à l'action et pour sar
l'économie est très utile parce que
l'économie quelque part elle représente
la quantité totale de gens puisque l
argent ne paye que des hommes en fait
l'économie vous dit combien il ya de
gens qui vont devoir s'impliquer pour
que le problème soit résolu
c'est ça que ça vous dit quelque part et
plus vous arrivez à résoudre le problème
avec peu de gens et plus votre moyen et
efficace le donc donc avoir un
raisonnement économique est quelque
chose qui a une étape du processus est
important mais c'est mais c'est pour
l'efficacité de l'action c'est pas pour
l'opportunité de l'action le donc
l'offre l'offre écologique classique
malheureusement elle est un peu elle a
du mal à monter en compétence sur ces
sujets et elle a du mal à abandonner ses
vieilles lunes donc en particulier en
france la mouvance écolo est très très
anti nucléaires et donc elle se retrouve
totalement en porte à faux sur le sujet
du changement climatique greenpeace n'a
quasiment jamais parlé du changement
climatique jusqu'à il ya quelques années
et même encore aujourd'hui ils sont
assez timides sur la question est
beaucoup moins agressif sur la question
que sur le nucléaire ils ont franchement
de mal quand même à faire le deuil de la
hiérarchie des nuisances qu'ils avaient
il ya 10 ou 15 ans donc la mouvance
environnementale est un peu et pas et
pas très bien outillé
la mouvance libérale elle est en conflit
d'objectif frontale elle est en conflit
d'objectif frontale parce que une vision
à long terme est une vision
planificatrice une vision planificatrice
et une vision dans laquelle on laisse
pas les gens faire exactement ce qu'ils
veulent donc dans une vision
planificatrice vous avez quand même un
cadre qui était imposé
j'ai envie de dire et si par exemple
vous voulez de vendre que des petites
voitures en france
ben vous dit pas les constructeurs en
droit de faire les voitures qu'ils
veulent maintenant ils ne font que des
petites voitures
donc vous donc dans ce genre de dans ce
genre de vision vous avez également la
nécessité
si par exemple vous avez un problème
parce que si vous mettez une contrainte
en france il en ya la concurrence va
faire moins cher que nous et c'est vous
avez besoin de retrouver le contrôle de
vos frontières pour être capable de
lutter contre ça c'est un truc qui est
par nature anti entre guillemets libéral
donc les gens qui sont très libéraux
dans la ram sont des gens qui ont du mal
à se faire aux problèmes qui sont là les
gens qui sont très sociaux ils ont
toujours été historiquement très
croissanciste parce que c'est le seul
moyen de faire progresser leurs venues
de tout le monde et c'est le premier
truc kylie kylie voilà donc le le parti
socialiste à l'époque où il y en avait 1
[Musique]
était quelque part beaucoup plus
soucieux de croissance économique que
les conservateurs lille en élisant d'ide
ont toujours été quelque part beaucoup
plus haussier donc si vous regardez si
vous mettez boutabout tous les
ingrédients convient d'évoquer c'est à
dire faut fonctionner il faut avoir des
solutions qui fonctionnent dans un monde
sans croissance il faut accepter l'idée
que l'économie n'est pas l'alpha et
l'oméga des indicateurs qui compte
et c est par ailleurs il faut avoir une
vision très pragmatique et conforme aux
faits de la hiérarchie des nuisances
environnementales
eh bien vous ne trouver aucune offre
politique qui arrive aujourd'hui à
conjuguer ça
ce qui veut dire probablement que le
jour où elle hébergera les mergerac de
quelque part et vous savez pas où vous
l'avez pas encore vu il ya une liste aux
européennes la qui s'appelait urgence
écologie qui sont rapprochés un peu
alors je pense que sur le nucléaire il
n'était pas encore totalement
on va dire là où j'aurais aimé les voir
mais globalement il ya ça s'en
rapprocher un peu c'est une espèce de
tentatives de mise en cohérence et sans
aucun aucune pub rien aucun passage
médias et j'en fais 2 % en vêtements
ridicule le mai mais cette offre
politique aujourd'hui elle émerge pas
alors l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
elles émergent pas il faut bien voir que
cette préoccupation qui nous rassemblent
dans cette salle aujourd'hui reste une
préoccupation qui à mon avis exprimés
sous cette forme est encore minoritaire
dans le pays
quand on discute avec les gens de la
convention citoyenne il vous explique
que dans leur quotidien le changement
climatique ça reste un sujet qui passe
totalement au dessus du ciboulot de tout
le monde et l'une des raisons nous
disent aussi les mêmes
c'est tout simplement que les gens n'ont
pas compris la gravité du problème c'est
à dire qu'il ya un défaut d'accès à
l'information qui fait que du coup le
sentiment d'urgence n'est pas là
et c'est pas quelque chose qui est
important dans la société
du coup il n'y a pas d'offre politique
qui émergent les municipales et les
approches l'un et dans une étude car 24
a estimé que si l'ensemble des actions
individuelles que peut prendre une
individus pour réduire son impact
carbone était vraiment mise en oeuvre
cela réduirait que de 25% son impact
carbone
similairement si on pose la même
question pour un maire parce que on
parle beaucoup de verts et d'écologie
pendant ces municipales et qu'elle est
l'emprise d'un maire sur l'impact
carbone de sa commune et de ses
habitants et ensuite est ce que vous
trouvez que le débat il est bien posée
pour l'instant pendant les municipales
sur l'écologie ou est-ce qu'on est
encore dans le greenwashing
lors de la dernière question est très
simple j'ai pas fait de revue de presse
donc je n'ai pas la réponse à votre
question je ne sais pas quelle place à
occuper l'environnement dans les
municipales j'avais ça il faut éplucher
tous les articles de presse de la sur le
la publication de carbone 4 alors en
fait sur un individu s'était pas 25
c'était 50 mais on avait considéré que
si on prenait la population dans son
ensemble
statistiquement le sommet de la
gaussienne il n'est jamais tout à gauche
et donc statistiquement tout le monde ne
fera pas le ce que nous on considère
être le maximum activable à l'échelle
d'un individu alors qu'est ce qu'on
avait mis là dedans on avait mis des
actes de consommation qui ne suppose pas
d'investissement arrêter de prendre
l'avion
arrêtez de manger de l'ail ans etc et
puis on avait mis les actes qui suppose
un investissement par exemple changer de
chaudière ou éventuellement changer de
voiture et si on avait mis tous à bout
tabou alors en fait on aurait pu être
encore plus extrémiste que ce qu'on a
fait on aurait pu arrêter d'acheter donc
50% c'était on va dire un effort
important accessible pas révolutionnaire
ça suppose pas de vivre de se mettre
totalement en marge de la société
les autres 50% il commence à être lié à
des choses qui dépendent moins de vous
par exemple en france 10 % de
l'empreinte carbone c'est les services
publics les services publics c'est
l'éducation nationale s'est plaint de
mètres carrés chauffé où vont les
enfants et c'est pas à la main d'un
ménage de décider de tourner ou pas le
thermostat de l'école où va son gamin
passe la main c'est pas non plus à sa
main de décidé de la construire ici
plutôt que là en béton plutôt qu'en bois
plus grand plus tôt plus petit et c'est
dans là dedans vous avez aussi le
fonctionnement de l'armée et c'est pas
la main non plus d'un ménage de décider
que le char leclerc le matin il va
avancer ou par avance et donc vous allez
ya également l'hôpital donc il ya une
partie des émissions qui sont gérés de
façon totalement collective et c'est
vrai également pour une partie des
émissions on va dire lié à des choses
qui restent raisonnablement vital et
pour lesquelles tant que l'industrie est
organisé comme elle est organisée
aujourd'hui c'est difficile de faire
baisser les émissions en ce qui concerne
les collectivités locales
alors il ya un certain nombre de choses
qui sont à la main des élus il ya la
réglementation de la mobilité qui est à
la main des élus locaux ils peuvent par
exemple limiter les vitesses ils peuvent
par exemple créer des voies cyclables
ils peuvent par exemple créer ou
supprimer des parkings ils peuvent ou
pas autorisés l'imperméabilisation du
supermarché juste en face et c'est donc
ils peuvent faire tout un tas de trucs
sur l'urbanisme et les déplacements ils
peuvent faire la promotion ou pas d'un
certain nombre d'activités économiques
les élus locaux ont parfois à leurs
mains
des zones d'activités dans lesquels
il ya il ya des îles font la retape pour
faire venir des gens ils peuvent ils
peuvent faire ou pas ce genre de choses
ils peuvent ou pas essayer de favoriser
un tourisme aéroportée plutôt que non
donc voilà mme hidalgo qui dit que paris
va être neutre en 2050
j'aimerais bien voir la quantité de
touristes japonais qu'elle a mis dans
son business plan à 2050
normalement 0 et c'est pareil pour les
acheteurs chinois du bon marché donc le
voilà donc il ya un
il ya tout un tas de trucs qui sont à la
main des élus locaux dans ces
municipales j'ai pas l'impression que
jusqu'à maintenant on parle énormément
d'environnement mais je me trompe
peut-être déjà j'ai pas l'impression
qu'on parle énormément des municipales
pour commencer enfin en ce moment il ya
le corps d'un virus qui se met de la
partie donc on parle un peu plus du
coronavirus voilà je n'ai pas
l'impression que ça il ya un truc dans
tiff sur lequel il faut il faut faire
attention c'est que quand on est
passionné par un sujet on a toujours
tendance à surestimer l'importance que
prend ce sujet pour la population dans
son ensemble et en particulier il ya un
biais très fort c'est que quand on est
passionné par un sujet on a plutôt
tendance à fréquenter des gens qui sont
aussi passionnés par le même sujet et
donc on a tendance à penser que tout le
monde est dans ce cas de figure je
encore une fois la réalité et la réalité
sociologique française c'est que
l'environnement aujourd'hui quand on dit
aux gens est ce que l'environnement vous
tarabuste il oui mais il vous en parle
pas spontanément tous les jours pour
rebondir sur le fait que vous avez que
vous avez dit que il ya simplement une
minorité qui est vraiment préoccupée
consciente changement climatique en
effet pour la plupart des gens ça reste
un sujet assez vague abstrait dont les
conséquences sont difficiles à
visualiser et pour d'autres c'est plutôt
l'angoissent qui prend le dessus et donc
le déni donc comment fédérer autour de
la lutte contre le changement climatique
est également comment rester motiver et
faire face à l' angoisse que peut
entraîner les menaces écologiques
j'ai pas compris notre action comment
rester motiver et faire face à l'
angoisse que peut entraîner les menaces
écologiques
si je reformule la question c'est
comment faire en sorte que les gens on
arrive à les informer sans les déprimés
c'est ça
on n'y arrive pas on n'y arrive pas
c'est à dire que il faut les informer et
derrière les accompagner parce que il va
y avoir une forme de courbes de deuil
c'est à dire qu'il ya un moment où on va
s'en prendre plein la figure et on va
dire mais c'est absolument horrible or
plus on fait rien c'est pour ça qu'une
fois je me rappelle très bien il y avait
j'avais fait une interview croisée avec
un avec le père spirituel de pablo
serving c'est à dire yves cochet qui est
un type assez rigolo je sais pas si ce
nom vous dira quelque chose parce qu'il
commence à être un peu âgées yves cochet
et c'était un ovni parce que je crois
que c'est le seul député de paris qui
s'est fait élire député de paris un
certain nombre de mandat avec pour seul
programme qu'on allait tous mourir
donc voila mais je veux penser qu'à fin
assez rigolo yves cochet il avait fait
un colloque sur le pic de production du
pétrole en 2003 à l'assemblée nationale
c'est à dire cinq ans avant qu'ils
n'arrivent pour de vrai pour le
conventionnel
il y avait un député et demi dans la
salle des tas de gens qui n'est pas de
l'assemblée il y avait un député et demi
qui était vu s'intéresser au sujet il
avait dit dans une interview que les
fêtes avec lui quand on commence à se
documenter sur ce sujet il faut pas
rester seul j'avais trouvé cette
remarque frappé au coin du bon sens ça
mais ce n était pas venu parce que moi
j'ai la chance de ne pas être seul à
carbone 4 il ya qu' une des bandes de
jeunes gens qu'on est là pour remonter
la moyenne d'âge mais il ya que y'a que
des jeunes passionnés
donc on n'est pas seul en plus on est
dans l'action
donc on est vraiment en août sortie de
l' angoisse au sens de tous les jours on
essaye de se creuser la cervelle pour
faire avancer le schmilblick dans la
bonne direction mais quand les gens
découvrent il faut absolument qu'il soit
accompagné il faut pas qu'il soit seul
c'est vraiment le truc important parce
que deux fêtes de toute façon ils vont
s'en prendre plein la figure notamment
moyen d'éviter ça alors après la nature
et ans calais nature humaine étant ce
qu'elle est on va quand même dû ressort
donc une fois qui est passée l'étape
france en ai pris plein la figure après
on commence à se creuser la cervelle
pour savoir ce qu'on peut faire et à ce
moment là ça commence à devenir
intéressant mais au début il n'y a pas
tellement moyen d'éviter la douche
écossaise
une dernière question sur
la vie professionnelle ce qui est une
question que beaucoup d'entre nous se
posent comment mener une vie
professionnelle en phase avec l'écologie
et selon vous est il préférable de
travailler pour des grosses entreprises
que l'on plante régulièrement du doigt
pour leur impact écologique afin de les
changer de l'intérieur
ou plutôt prendre part à des petits
projets dans totale cohérence avec les
problématiques écologiques
il faut alors je vais
vous répondre d'une manière un peu c'est
pas vraiment biaisé en fait je pense
qu'il faut travailler pour des gens plus
que pour des structures
il n'y a pas de vérité universelle vous
avez des grandes entreprises
alors les grandes entreprises sont des
univers sont plus contraints globalement
que les petites mais c'est des univers
qui ont plus de moyens dans une grande
entreprise par ailleurs pour faire la
révolution on l'a fait rarement à l'âge
auquel on a envie de faire la révolution
donc vous avez envie de faire la
révolution à votre âge
sauf que quand vous allez rentrer dans
une entreprise vous êtes débutant vous
connaissez pas bien le métier de
l'entreprise vous n'avez pas de prise
sur les hautes sphères parce que le
patron il est en moyenne plus humaine
plus 25 par rapport à vous parce que
vous n'avez pas la main sur de
l'arbitrage des arbitrages budgétaires
qui compte parce que et c'est donc le
c'est le grand paradoxe c'est qu'au
moment où vous avez envie de faire la
révolution vous n'avez pas les moyens de
faire la révolution puis une fois que
vous aurez mon âge et vous serez en
crottés vous en aurez moins envie le
monde est mal fait mais le mais mais
mais pour répondre à votre question donc
si vous avez la chance
en fait il faut chercher j'ai comme les
truffes et il faut chercher ou les
champignons et puis un jour vous aurez
peut-être la chance de trouver quelque
chose qui sera pas trop mal comme
attelage c'est à dire la proximité avec
quelqu'un qui a la possibilité de faire
des arbitrages qui vous délègue assez
vite mais vous aurez toujours une
période d'apprentissage la capacité à
suggérer ou à louer ou à réfléchir et
dans un créneau dans lequel la
possibilité de changer vous aurez vous
une appréciation en propre qui vous
permet de penser que c'est pas du
bullshit intégral parce que
malheureusement vous avez aussi cette
difficulté c'est que le greenwashing est
omniprésent dans le domaine qui me
concerne en les grandes techniques de
greenwashing en a quelques-unes que je
peux vous apprendre qu'ils sont très
simples la première s'appelle confondre
un emile donc dans une entreprise qui
fait 10 villes personnes le service
comme passe son temps à parler des dix
personnes qui font des trucs biens
techniques greenwashing marche très bien
la deuxième technique non je confonds à
emile sais je m'appelle air france tous
les jours je cram de jeu pas combien de
centaines de milliers de tonnes de
kérosène et je vous explique que j'ai
mis des ruches sur le toit
voilà ça c'est la deuxième technique de
greenwashing qui marche extrêmement bien
une troisième technique de greenwashing
qui marche très bien qu'ils aient
consiste à ne compter les problèmes que
dans le périmètre dans lequel vous êtes
en train de les résoudre c'est aussi un
truc qui marche très bien
donc dans mon cas de figure par exemple
vous fait un bide au lieu de compter
l'ensemble des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre qui sont la contrepartie de
votre activité dont vous dépendez
vous ne comptez que celles qui vont bien
et sur lesquels vous avez une
possibilité de faire un petit quelque
chose alors je vais vous donner un
exemple vous êtes un centre commercial
un centre commercial vous savez c'est un
gros entrepôts donc pour qu'un centre
commercial puisse vivre il faut
fabriquer les produits qui vont être
vendus donc quand monsieur poitrine à
l'ancien cette école était le patron du
dubai l'essentiel des émissions des
centres commerciaux possédé par unibail
et dont unibail dépend des c'était le
fait qu'ils les camions qui livrent les
marchandises des gens qui viennent en
bagnole dans les centres commerciaux a
fallu avait beaucoup de centre-ville
mais et que surtout qu'on fabrique tous
les produits qui sont vendus dans ses
centres commerciaux si on arrête de
faire des ordinateurs apple
eh bien monsieur poitrinal père la fnac
et s'il perd la fnac hyper du pognon
donc le les émissions il faut que
j'allais remettre les sponsors les
émissions dont il dépend des c'était
tout ce qui allait de la fabrication des
produits vendus jusqu'à la logistique
des clients qui venaient se servir dans
ces centres qu'est-ce qu'on compte en
général dans ce genre d'endroit quand
vous faites un vous comptez les
émissions de la chaudière du centre
commercial on s'en fout donc ça c'est
aussi une très bonne technique de
greenwashing qui consiste à ne compter
qu'un tout petit morceau du machin enfin
voila vous en avez d'autres des
techniques de greenwashing
alors le problème c'est que ça demandera
peu de technicité d'être capable de les
débusquer
si vous n'êtes pas familier du métier de
l'entreprise si vous n'êtes pas familier
de la façon dont ça fonctionne
physiquement jeune diplômé vous allez
avoir beaucoup de mal à comprendre qu'on
est en train de vous raconter des
carabistouilles quand on vous dit qu'on
fait les choses bien
une dernière technique de greenwashing
c'est de promettre des trucs qui
n'arriveront jamais
alors par exemple c'est pas un exemple
d'entreprise mais par exemple
madame elisabeth bornes qui fut aussi
une voisine puisqu'elle était dans la
chambre en face de la mienne il ya
quasiment 40 ans a expliqué il n'y a pas
longtemps à la radio que c'était pas
grave de faire le quatrième terminal de
roissy parce qu'on va les faire voler
des avions zéro carbone et d'hydrogène
donc si vous allez travailler chez adp
par exemple on pourra me dire mais pas
de problème les avions vont être
décarbonés parce que ils voleront à
l'hydrogène
donc le donc donc c'est donc il ya ces
difficultés là aujourd'hui c'est que
beaucoup d'entreprises ont compris que
c'était un sujet pour votre génération
comme l ont pas travaillé le sujet
jusqu'à maintenant comme l ont rien fait
et bien font la seule chose qui à court
terme et en leurs moyens et leurs
capacités c'est de raconter n'importe
quoi et il ya un certain nombre de gens
avec qui ça marche parce que vous n'avez
pas les moyens techniques de comprendre
qu'on est en train de vous raconter
n'importe quoi dans les petites
entreprises vous allez avoir le
symétrique exacte de la grande c'est à
dire que vous allez avoir des entités
qui seront moins influente sur
l'évolution du monde où vous serez plus
rapidement au plus près de dieu ça vous
aurez plus rapidement d une capacité
d'initiative mais qu'ils porteront sur
des sujets qui seront nécessairement un
peu moins à effet de levier
et quelque part c'est un peu comme vous
le sentez
non mais voilà il ya pas de ya pas deux
pas trois sets pirates merci beaucoup on
va passer aux questions du public
peut-être juste je suis désolé je pose
une dernière question je vous volent la
parole par rapport à la positive que
vous montrez que vous montriez tout à
l'heure sur les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre ou la digitalisation la
prétendue digitalisation n'avait pas
d'impact
est ce que c'était c'est la première
question est ce que c'était la même
chose pour les émissions par personne
par habitant puisque la population
augmenter mais aussi les [ __ ] comme ils
consomment plus c'est juste qu'ils sont
par personne a augmenté aussi et en
terme de démographie est ce que vous
êtes en faveur de politiques qui visent
à réguler la natalité comme on a pu le
voir en chine ce qui a été arrêté dans
les pays développés en europe notamment
en france
alors je pense qu'il faut au moins
commencer en discuter
aujourd'hui la la question de la
population c'est très rigolo parce qu'il
ya un jeu passe très gros mais dans les
années 70 il ya un livre qui était
sortie qui s'appelait la bombe p et à ce
moment l'auteur du livre avait expliqué
que la terre allait devenir surpeuplées
et que ça allait être très emmerdant et
aujourd'hui où la terre est
effectivement surpeuplé
c'est un débat qui est très peu présent
aujourd'hui c'est intéressant de voir
que je sais pas si c'est une réaction de
dei
alors je pense que oui je pense qu'il
faut en parler et je pense qu'il ya un
certain nombre de choses
alors comme dans tous les sujets il faut
commencer par les trucs les plus faciles
dit autrement quand on essaye de
commencer à infléchir une orientation
faut commencer par les trucs les plus
indolore c'est quoi les trucs les plus
indolore aujourd'hui c'est essayer de
changer les schémas culturels des gens
qui ont beaucoup d'enfants pour qu'il en
ait un peu moins
vous avez beaucoup de pays dans lesquels
les femmes ont beaucoup d'enfants qui
sont des pays en fait qui ont accédé
très vite à des techniques modernes
d'adduction d'eau d'épuration de satiété
alimentaires etc
mais le la démographie n'a pas suivi
c'est à dire qu'on a conservé un modèle
culturel dans lequel on fait plein
d'enfants pour se prémunir contre des
problèmes qui aujourd'hui n'existe plus
alors il problème qui aujourd'hui
n'existe plus c'est quoi c'est la
mortalité infantile avant on avait plein
d'enfants que j'avais plein qui bourré
tout simplement et ensuite l'absence de
solidarité
c'est à dire que on fait plein d'enfants
se disant on a bien qui va s'occuper de
moi dans mes vieux jours
quand vous avez un système de solidarité
organisée depuis quand les retraites
vous avez moins besoin de vous organiser
votre système à vous qui s'appelle faire
des enfants donc dans ces pays là la
france comme tous les pays occidentaux à
un moyen d'action qui s'appelle l'aide
au développement et l'ancien chef
économiste de l'afd de l' agence
française de développement donc et le la
banque
enfin la banque de développement
bilatéral de la france qui s'appelle
gaël giraud et qui est prêtre jésuite
apprécié ce qui va suivre avait dit je
suis assez d'accord avec lui la france
ne devrait faire que trois choses dans
son aide au développement elle devrait
pas du tout aidé les gens à avoir des
panneaux solaires des ponts des routes
des aéroports c'est pourquoi on oublie
tout ça parce que toute façon autant que
la démographie est galopante ils vont
tous vers la guerre et nous aussi on ne
devrait faire que trois choses
au titre de l'aide au développement on
devrait faire de l'éducation et de
lampes power nantes je prends comme on
dit en français des femmes
on devrait faire de l'accès aux moyens
de contraception alors qu' évidemment
pose des tas de problèmes culturels etc
qui est un endroit où on considère que
les choses se font pas et on devrait
mettre en place des systèmes de
solidarité qui vont au delà de la maille
familiale donc des systèmes de
protection sociale diverses et variées
il devrait faire que ça on oublie les
routes les ponts les machins et c'est
sans fin en fait les trois on limite la
démographie et en france
et comme dans les autres pays
occidentaux on a aussi eu une discussion
à avoir là-dessus alors vous vous
rappelez que rocard enfin vous rappelez
pas parce que vous avez pas connu rocard
mais sauf quelques cheveux gris dans la
salle avait dit il ya quelques à
l'époque où il était premier ministre je
crois on ne peut pas accueillir toute la
misère du monde en france c'était une
façon un peu violente toléré par
quelqu'un qui était au parti socialiste
alors que si c'était un rassemblement
national ça serait pas toléré de faire
remarquer qu' il faut se poser la
question de la limite quantitative des
gens qui peuvent vivre en bonne harmonie
quelque part et pour moi c'est pas un
débat qui est il légitime il faut pas le
faire de manière et 2
il faut pas le faire je pense que c'est
des questions qu'il faut se poser est ce
que alors qu'on est 8 milliards sur
terre il faut continuer à avoir un
système fiscal nataliste en france ça se
discute très clairement ça se discute
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on en discute je
suis pas sûr que tout le monde serait
d'accord avec moi de moi je suis même
pas sûr de savoir quel avis exactement
j'aurais par contre je suis absolument
certain qu'il faudrait en discuter
oui du coup sa voûte en discuter bonjour
monsieur jancovici
donc pour me présenter je m'appelle
thomas je fais partie du master
développement durable à hec donc on est
un peu perçu comme les bobos du campus
mais je pense que ça va changer
j'ai deux questions à vous poser la
première question c'est comment
quand on parle de croissance
démographique croissance démographique
veut dire plus d'énergie
et la croissance démographique viendra
des pays en voie de développement c'est
des pays qui goûte tout juste
au pouvoir d'achat etc des pays qu'on
doit embarquer avec nous vers ce retour
vers des énergies plus propres
comment est ce qu'à votre avis
intellectuellement politiquement on
embarque les leaders de ceux de ces pays
là si ce n'est par contrainte est ma
deuxième question c'est est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer un petit peu plus
en dit est ce qui ne va pas avec
l'hydrogène et en quoi c'est pas une
solution sable donc ces deux questions
totalement différente je vais commencer
par la deuxième parce qu'elle est
techniquement plus facile ce qui ne va
pas avec l'hydrogène c'est qu'on n'en
trouve pas dans la nature
donc si vous voulez avoir de l'hydrogène
à votre disposition il faut commencer
par le fer et le faire physiquement ça
veut dire que l'hydrogène en fait vous
ne trouvez pas isolé dans la nature si
vous ne trouvez pas de molécules
d'hydrogène vous trouver plein
d'hydrogène mais associé à d'autres
atomes par exemple dans un truc vous
buvez le moins souvent possible au
profit du whisky qui s'appelle l'eau eh
bien vous avez plein d'hydrogène associé
à de l'oxygène pour récupérer cet
hydrogène
il faut casser la liaison entre
l'hydrogène et l'oxygène et vous allez
utiliser pour casser cette liaison plus
d'énergie en fait très exactement
l'énergie vous allez récupérer dans la
combustion
mais comme il ya des pertes
intermédiaire en fait vous allez
utiliser plus d'énergie pour dissocier
l'oxygène et l'hydrogène que vous
n'allez en récupérer derrière dans la
combustion de l'hydrogène dont vous avez
besoin d'énergie au départ pour
dissocier l'hydrogène et de l'oxygène
donc si cette énergie vous allez devoir
le trouver dans la nature
la manière dont on fait l'hydrogène
aujourd'hui alors de l'hydrogène
aujourd'hui on en produit plein c'est un
produit chimique qui est produit de
façon courante tout simplement parce que
l'hydrogène est indispensable à la
synthèse de l'ammoniac l'ammoniac cnh 3
donc de l'azoté de l'hydrogène ont
produit la zot en le récupérant dans
l'air ça c'est très simple et
l'hydrogène on le produit avec indisposé
une technique qui est que vous mélangez
du gaz naturel ch4 avec de l'eau vous
chauffer très fort et vous récupérez de
l'hydrogène et du co2 donc dans le
processus de production de l'hydrogène
vous avez du co2 qui est produit par la
réaction chimique est par ailleurs comme
il faut chauffer très fort et que vous
allez faire ça avec du gaz vous allez
aussi émettre du co2 avec le gaz que
vous avez brûlé pour chauffer très fort
le résultat des courses c'est que une
voiture à hydrogène
aujourd'hui c'est à peu près autant de
co2 avec de l'hydrogène produit de cette
manière qu une voiture à pétrole
c'est aller dans les bonnes conditions
10 ou 20% de moins mais ça change pas
les ordres de grandeur si vous produisez
l'hydrogène en électrisant de l'eau donc
pas par thermolyse du méthane mais en
électrolyse de l'eau avec le mix
électrique allemand actuel la voiture à
hydrogène et deux fois pire que la
voiture à pétrole
donc c'est ça mon problème avec
l'hydrogène alors les gens disent à un
jour on va le produire avec des énergies
renouvelables donc ça sera zéro carbone
l'énergie renouvelable plus et c'est
d'abord les énergies renouvelables sont
pas héros carbone une éolienne ces dix
grammes de co2 km heure avant stockage
un panneau solaire c'est 50 grammes de
co2 avant stockage
donc c'est moins que le gaz qui en fait
400 mais c'est pas héros ensuite il va
falloir stocker l'hydrogène vous allez
perdre 1 % au passage si vous le conte
privé 50% si vous le liquéfier donc vous
voyez c'est pas 0
c'est moins éventuellement mais c'est
pas trop donc le l'hydrogène est un truc
est connue depuis très longtemps
l'hydrogène a été utilisé dans les
premiers moteurs à combustion interne
donc c'est un truc qu'on connaît depuis
très très longtemps il faut savoir que
la créativité humaine à développer à peu
près tout ce à quoi on pense aujourd'hui
il ya un siècle on a tout testé puis on
va dire ce qui marche le mieux vraiment
ces trucs à combustion interne avec du
pétrole
on va prendre ça la voiture électrique
sera un siècle enfin tout ça tout ça un
siècle le saas est la réponse à la
première question c'est ça c'est ça mon
problème avec l'hydrogène
c'est que c'est un truc qui est qui en
pratique qui doit être fabriqué et
aujourd'hui la façon dont on peut le
fabriquer ne remplit pas le cahier des
charges qui est que ça doit décarbonés
là la réponse à
la première question que j'ai déjà
oublié c'était non non juste dites-moi
ce que c'était ah oui la question des
pays en voie la horde eu de réponse la
réponse taquine c'est que il ya que
depuis qu'on a après le changement
climatique que les français se soucient
des pays en développement avant il en
avait strictement rien à [ __ ]
parce que s'il en avait eu quelque chose
à [ __ ] au lieu de leur donner 0 7% du
pib on leur donnerait 20 % du pib
d'accord si vous avez des enfants et que
vraiment vos enfants sont dans la merde
vous n'allez pas leur donner 0 7% ce que
vous gagnez un bien sûr donc le le fait
même que jusqu'à maintenant on leur
donnait que très peu d'argent c'est bien
la preuve que jusqu'à maintenant on s'en
foutait et alors depuis que il ya le
changement climatique
ces gens là sont devenus le cache sexe
pour justifier notre propre consommation
d'accord ah ben on va quand même pas se
priver parce que eux ils sont juste pas
de sujet alors comment est ce qu'on fait
eh bien on fait la seule chose que vous
apprenez ici c'est à dire la mode ont
fait du mimétisme
c'est du reste comme ça qu'on élève nos
enfants est donc la seule le sale seule
manière d'essayer de les embarquer j'y
viens d'essayer de les embarquer c'est
de commencer par faire nous et qui se
disent tiens c'est peut-être pas compte
faire la même chose parce que l'homme
est un animal minetti qu il y en a une
partie qu'ils feront
et parce que si nous on commence à ramer
dans la bonne direction de toute façon
on mettra notre créativité au service de
la découverte de formes d'organisation
de techniques de et ses techniques ce
n'est pas juste des objets si je veux
dire des façons de procéder qui seront
éventuellement ray exploitable par
l'autre dit autrement je ne vois pas de
meilleure solution que de commencer à
faire nous mêmes je vais finir par un
exemple qui est évident pour moi si vous
avez quelqu'un qui est en train de
passer de une à trois cigarettes par
jour
la personne qui en fut vain et quand
même pas très bien placé pour lui
d'arrêter de fumer quoi
bonsoir je m'appelle noémie je suis une
ancienne la chaussée je suis revenue
spécialement jouer pour la conférence
j'ai une question qui est d'ordre
presque conceptuel quand vous disiez que
la diminution des émissions de co2 était
pas compatible avec une augmentation du
pib
vous aurez aussi un la porte vers la
décroissance et de mon humble
compréhension aujourd'hui la
décroissance c'est plutôt un anti-modèle
on nous dise qu'on ne doit pas prendre
comme variable d'amélioration de des
choses est ce que vous avez vous voyez
où vous conceptualiser un modèle qui est
des variables qui sont acceptables
d'augmentation de la qualité de vie et
de diminution de l'exploitation des
ressources naturelles et le cas échéant
est ce que vous voyez des façons de
transition et versa comment fait parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a un peu dans une mine
en passe alors là la décroissance pour
moi est un élément du cahier des charges
c'est pas un souhait dit autrement ce
n'est pas un projet de société
c'est une contrainte mais je pense que
la contrainte on va l'avoir je leur dis
dans un monde où c'est les machines qui
produit si vous avez moins de machines
qui produisent vous avez moins de
production et donc vous avez moins de
pib c'est aussi bête que ça
et comme la première question qu'on m'a
posée c est ce qu on pourrait pas avoir
finalement autant de machines qui
produisent avec une énergie décarbonée
et j'ai répondu dont moi j'y crois pas
enfin les calculs d'ordre de grandeur
que j'ai faits montrent que je ne crois
pas que ce soit possible
ça veut donc dire que si on diminue
rapidement la quantité d'énergie
fossiles qu'on utilise ça veut dire
qu'on diminue la quantité totale
d'énergie qu'on utilise et donc ça veut
dire qu'on diminue le parc de machines
en fonctionnement qu'on utilise donc on
baisse le pib est ce que on peut y
échapper
ma réponse donc et non est-ce que ça
doit être vendu en tant que tel ce qu'on
doit dire aux gens
décroissance a levé vous toussez dit
décroissance c'est génial non j'y crois
pas une seconde
par contre ce que je crois c'est que
ceux qui ont la charge de la conduite
des affaires doivent à partir de
maintenant essayer de trouver des moyens
de donner espoir aux gens dans un
contexte dans lequel par ailleurs il va
pas y avoir plus de moyens
donc c'est un exercice beaucoup plus
difficile que d'essayer d'en chanter les
foules quand il ya rab de sucettes pour
tout le monde c'est très clair ça
renvoie également à la question qui a
été posée tout à l'heure de l'offre
politique ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
les généraux de cette guerre il n'existe
pas c'est pas ou pas encore mais c'est
évident que c'est ça les éléments du
cahier des charges
alors si on en reste à la partie comment
est-ce qu'on s'organise au mieux dans ce
genre de contexte
parce qu'il ya cette question là aussi
dans celle que vous m'avez posé est bien
là la réponse on commence à essayer de
demander un certain nombre de gens de
réfléchir à la question et donc moi un
truc j'adorerais c'est que au lieu que
100% des économistes qui font de
l'économie conceptuel ne pense qu'à une
seule chose qui et comment on fait
revenir une croissance alors ça dépend
pas d'eux ça dépend juste de la quantité
d'énergie qu'on a qu'il y en ait une
partie qui commence à se creuser la
cervelle pour savoir comment on
fonctionne au mieux dans une société qui
est en contraction
voilà ça ça m'intéresserait un peu plus
dit autrement on ne postule pas qu'il ne
dépend que notre volonté de faire
revenir pib parce qu'enfin la croissance
du pib parce que c'est pas de sac ça
dépend on postule qu'il va baisser et à
ce moment la question c'est comment
est-ce qu'on s'organise au mieux alors
il ya un truc par exemple que j'ai
utilisé l'expression pour la première
fois il ya quelques il ya quelques
semaines mais qui illustre un truc qu'il
faudrait faire dans ce genre de contexte
par exemple c'est une hiérarchie des
renoncements
est ce que j'entends ce genre de
contexte vous préféré abandonner votre
abonnement à netflix ou vous préférez
abandonné 1 degré dans votre logement ou
est-ce que vous préférez abanda voilà
c'est bon on n'a strictement aucune
aujourd'hui manière de gérer ça parce
que on a zéro travail conceptuel sur la
question et j'ai encore une fois je ne
parle pas d'en avoir envie je parle de
comprendre comment on s'organise au
mieux dans ce monde là quand les
astronautes sont allés sur la lune
il y avait encore un élément dans le
cahier des charges qu'il n'ya pas
d'oxygène dans le vide et donc on essaye
de se démerder de telle sorte qu'il
reste vivant quand même bon et
vivant dans des conditions qui sont
quand même un peu moins sympa quand vous
allez en vacances au bord de la mer
donc le il faut absolument qu'on ait des
gens qui comprennent qu'ils
réfléchissent sur comment est-ce qu'on
peut aussi organiser au mieux dans dans
ce genre de monde et aujourd'hui cette
discipline reste à inventer
elle n'existe pas et quand vous en
parler à des économistes en leur
expliquant qu'ils devraient peut-être
commencer à se pencher sur la question
yves auriol sonné comme si vous aviez bu
une demi-bouteille de whisky quoi ça
n'intéresse personne pour le moment mais
c'est un drame on va on va enfin je veux
dire ça a beaucoup de valeur de faire ça
nous sommes obligés de clôturer la
conférence conférence et arrêter les
questions propos des contraintes de
temps et vous pourrez vous diriger vers
le buffet il ya les pompiers qui le met
dehors
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai moi j'ai pas de train à prendre
donc si les pompiers nous met dehors et
nous mettre dehors mais sinon j'ai pas
trop en prendre qu il ya un cocktail à
la sortie si vous voulez poser des
questions